[Music]
all right
what's going on around talk to me what
is going on
let me know how the levels are sounding
you already know what it is
hustle and motivate my man what's going
on brother
massive wreck oh wow thank you brother
round two oh wow you can't
you can't wait for solve to say that
name
[Laughter]
akw what's going on man
rocket corey hey run what's going on
thank you sir
design what's going on brother i saw the
tweet thank you very
much appreciate it got adequate building
addict talk to him
what's going on guys chilling chilling
he's chilling right now
so you know it's a big one today yeah
lord paris will get him in
soon but
acg
thank you brother so yeah man we're
gonna get
he said i was also under the table and
yeah gary whatever was in his bag on
that shout out to the um
kind of funny ex-cast yeah he was in his
bag that anti-nintendo red
yo that was a good one but yeah man we
gonna get this thing
rocking we'll get uh saw the king will
be up in here soon and
um oh wow we got a we got an og we got a
veteran
we got squirly what's going on man no
more yellow knight squirrely right east
coast whirly
we'll see what's going on but yeah we'll
get uh paris up in here in the fuel
and get this thing rocking so we will be
back
talk to you in a minute
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not
mind go ahead and uh find yourself a
spot get comfortable grab a snack
do all that good stuff that we need to
do and um you know we're about to get
started i
am well it's not important who i am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron lords
podcast right now as we speak and uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
but coming to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable
and they say i'm better than money
because you can bank on me being
accountable i know a million rappers
that don't want to be on a song with me
that's understandable i kill a beat and
they want to compare me to freddie and
jason i'd rather be hannibal they'd be
like why use a video game just be
original y'all so dramatical i know it's
random but i am addicted to flipping the
sample and making it flammable this is
[Music]
i ain't here to boy you ain't gotta say
it i'm embarrassed for you i've always
been a nerd never been a loser making
voltron with a gang of cougars and i'm
going places better tell her uber cause
it's pretty hard to sleep on freddy
krueger
let's do that again hear you hear you
man welcome to the show if you would not
mind go ahead and uh find yourself a
spot get comfortable grab a snack
do all that good stuff that we need to
do and um you know we're about to get
started i
am well it's not important who i am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron lord's
podcast right now as we speak and uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all haven't messed up and turned
me to an animal and headless be swearing
but that's all a part of me being
accountable and they say i'm better than
money because you can bank on me being
accountable i know a million rappers
that don't want to be on a song with me
that's understandable i kill a beat and
they want to compare me to freddie and
jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable
this is that yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame
still i'll be running collecting them
reigns you just a target when i'm in the
range i was the hardest to start
regardless back when you was messaging
people on aim
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
um
[Music]
always been a nerd never been a loser
making voltron with the gang of cougars
and i'm going places better tell her
uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
freddy krueger
let's do that again
[Music]
a proclamation
[Music]
the pack and be like a young wolf but
then they would mistake me for addict if
i can imagine this cooler give you some
advice and invite your girl to your
squadron
cause if you don't give her that option
you're gonna be single player like siren
you're gonna get tossed in the bushes by
king david
royalty and not a pretender detrimental
to an elemental what's an avatar to a
knee bender i gotta be neato
i know it's my destiny worked a cognito
who cares if you fly if you steal a
mosquito you swear you ain't something
but really
you like to collect stuff and that's
cool but i got bad news
even if he really was that jew king
david still be the king of the statues
since the juvenile i've been cursed with
a curse to be musical and if you hate it
we'll meet in a crucible wasn't it
nothing it's cool and it's beautiful we
let you know that your dreams are
pursuable whatever you want to do then
is doable if you got work on a sunday is
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle
on the lord's day
if you got work on a sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on the lord's day
[Music]
all right and we are live here you hear
you
welcome to the iron lords podcast and
also live on lords of gaming.net
episode number 206 and it's another
glorious sunday we're back at the round
table on the lord's day
i'm very excited about our special guest
and we've got capcom and sony's alleged
contract
firewalk studios multiplayer ip and
playstation video pass to discuss
so we're going to get right into it i
want to introduce a lord whose passion
for video game cinema and anime
is only matched by his tremendous drive
and insightful perspectives
within the gaming media landscape
introducing the creating host of the
paris youtube
twitch channels and the co-host of the
gamertag radio
and kinda funny xcast the lord of chill
drone
commentary fellow destiny fan
who correctly recognizes mass effect 2
as one of the greatest video games ever
made
sovereign
parish parish it was it was it was nice
live from cali and kind enough to make
his debut
into the realm of the lord my man
lord paris lily how you doing sir yo
that was the most professional bougie
introduction i think i've ever had i
really appreciate it but uh man
i'm i'm very excited to be here really
because i've been big fans of all of you
for a while i've been
i've been sneak watching you know my
little comment in the chat every now and
again
you know what i mean but um you know
like like i told cognito way way back a
few months ago when i originally was
trying to you know trying to get me to
come on
i was like bro i can't do the 10 a.m on
sunday i got to watch football
remember i remember we got to wait we
gotta wait on that one
seriously i'm excited to be here thank
you thank you for having me
absolute president you're a lord of what
you do we just got rocked together on
the x cast
but in the meantime what have you been
playing many games you've been playing
um i've been playing return on the
playstation 5
and the one thing that i can say about
it is
wow wow okay okay i'll just say i'll
leave it at that
if you follow me on twitter and if
you've seen other people been playing it
so far during preview um
it's not easy game i'll i'll just leave
it at that but um
i'll have more to say soon uh been i've
been jumping back into destiny 2.
uh because i got it and like i told you
i need someone to hold my hand
like i'm five years old get me all the
way because i'm like
i'm almost 1300 power level now because
i
took a break because i've been playing
other stuff so i i just got to get
ramped back up and i want to do the rage
and
all that stuff too but um well you can
do the raid at 13.
yeah yeah yeah yeah you can drag them
through just yeah yeah just
just
he's light like he ain't going to get
touched by anything yeah
you're good bro yeah i keep them
downstairs with me in the hard parts
[Music]
no doubt man absolute pleasure man we
got a fun show lined up uh soft you want
to get a couple of those
in now we're gonna start
the day off correctly with a new member
to the realm put the crest
in the chat for mass error
oh that's my kid yeah i love him
fantastic then we have gerald mack with
the five dollar super chat
shout out to the four horsemen of gaming
no podcast does it better
all hail the iop thank you sir thank you
then we have flame with the two dollar
super chat everyone gangsta till cog
brings out
introduced that's a staple you know
then we got gaming forte with the two
dollar super chat hey lois have a great
show
hey king
and you're oh sean capri what's up
brother and you already know
we got the four horsemen of gaming those
original lords of the realm here at the
round table with a little bit of time
sensitive intros because of paris my
co-host with the co-host
my brother from another mother the
difficult game conqueror lord of his own
world and the how
of the young wolf my man lord addict how
we doing sir
doing pretty good man the first thing i
want to say is if you ain't played
octopath travel i don't know what you do
with your life
it isn't what you should be doing i'll
say that like
i still don't think it was worth 60
dollars
well you got it in the game i'm
referring to the switch people
okay so but but the game the game is
phenomenal i
i do think that uh it's been underrated
and i can understand why people don't
like it because there's story issues
with the game
but as far as like gameplay like the
gameplay of this
on a jrpg standpoint is up there with
like final fantasy
6 wow like it's it's really good
it's amazing what kind of unique combos
you can have like i can make
i could do a unique combo where none of
my people can get hit i can keep doing
it over and over again because i found
busted combinations
[Music]
out to those plus the combination
because that's the reason i beat the
gods of this game because i heard the
gods for breaking you down i already was
yeah yeah
he'll jump in my chat just to say what's
up king this game is killing me
funny remember when i told you i'm going
to go find another one
still listen he jumps in my chat he goes
i'm gonna beat up this 81 year old woman
so it's a guy that's inside my chat that
doesn't know
where the context of what she's wearing
who's beating up 81 year old women
i said no man that's an octopath
traveler he don't know who you are
[Music]
it was not my fault they put like a very
rare item behind some old chicken
octopad traveler travel
that's been it right okay and
of course we have our most technical
gaming lord the solo gamer who lives for
the single player selfish experience
and also the soft dominus the lord
of clarity and lord patriot of the iron
bank
my man lord sovereign how we doing sir
what up what up
i'm doing well what's going on what's
going on i've been chilling man i've
been doing good i
uh i've been testing out that uh xcloud
beta
on the on the pc i got the invite so
shout out to xbox for that um
do it very nice very nice show on the go
on the go um but it's still like i i
play
like i play the moments mode i'll play
the home run derby mode on that
uh don't try to play an actual game at
least not yet so no online play
yeah the pitching you know because in
pitching i like to play all-star and up
so right yes if you miss your spots
you're done
yes no so using pinpoint the new
pitching or
which one i still have yet to wrap my
head around that pinpoint pitching
like because it it's about it's about
rhythm
right and the actual motion itself so
you have to do both
okay so i like using pulse pitching me
too i'm posting okay
so uh but we'll see because we got to
talk to aims and see how this league is
going to run and what we're going to be
what we're going to be playing so and
then yeah i played a little bit locally
i was playing on my my xbox just a
little bit ago uh some home run derby
online had to smoke these fools you know
how
the baseball kick is how i do you know
you're a beast i'll try to catch you
early before you got nice
[Laughter]
no doubt and of course we have the
incredible hulk of this
aka the access gamer
the prophet of xbox king of the statues
who demands nothing less than that
premium experience
it is the leader of the fraud alert
movement
beloved lord king how are we doing sir
better than my man
i would like to say uh arrogance
and uh feeling yourself
is the full is the tool of the fool um
he went there super overconfident he
didn't respect him at all he didn't
respect his power like he said he didn't
feel it the first time
you felt it this time you didn't feel it
the first time because he was up against
the ropes half the time taking elbows
all right so and you know he switched up
the game plan as a true champion would
and he took him where he wanted to take
him and he did exactly what he wanted to
do when he hit him upside his head and
that sweat
reached the fifth row that's a good
night bro
it's time to go not to jump right it it
it shocked me
because i never never come back did that
kind of finish
we all know uh camaro's the better
wrestler we get it
but it was just one of those things to
see mozville stretched
it it's surreal i know why didn't you
doing why didn't
uh uh shocked me the first fight
he tried the same punch in the first
round and
whiffed it by this much and i'm pretty
sure he practiced that and saw the video
just like me
but i want to give a shout out to rose
rose oh yeah that's
all gross baby i thought that fight was
going to go longer i really did i
really actually thought it was going to
go at least two to three rounds
that kick to the side of her head showed
her a
different world i was i was different i
was so glad for rose because rose
her last couple of fights i just thought
mentally she wasn't in it and
and she came back and she was she was
there a hundred percent
and john wiley is no joke she's nice
yeah she's nice man but you saw her
when she was holding the belt i loved
that she was shaking because
she achieved whatever goals she put in
her head in training camp all right
past that listen have not played destiny
all week
wow i have been in college oh i have
graduated the harvard people i am sad in
harvard camp
of the outrider all right there's bills
baby
i have and this is no lie i
have uh uh what is that um
uh the compound book oh my god you know
the old black
i have that with different builds
with air sets written down wow and the
times that i beat
the tier 15 by myself wow with
what i was wearing and how long and what
was my power output in the dps
i'm not gonna lie you did i didn't
respect the game in a demo yep i have
the
product you said ps3 graphics that i
quote yeah yeah yeah no i said no no
i said player model player yes yes i
said the player models i don't care what
anybody said there was a ps3 player
model
um but i must say this shout out to phil
dominus maximus
because he said some point in time he
did that for you
he realized this was a hit
whoever is on his team that has
has that eye sarah paris yeah sarah
yes yeah let's let's let's she listen
to us let me tell you she is his rob
gronkowski
oh yeah okay oh yeah yeah all right she
is his safety net she is that that that
tight end is going to get up the field
is going to make sure that she catch
that ball and take it home
she's going to help him win and
it's stuff like this that changes the
narrative going forward i
swear i have not played a game this much
this diligently since destiny and
and for me for taking me away from my
love my girlfriend
you know it got to be something it got
to be
himself the shinobi lord cognito
spreading that realness to the roman iop
not telling what you want to hear but
what you need to hear same thing as king
pretty much
uh shout out to ibonte's last word we
had the legendary tie guy travis from um
five team chat on he was in a rare form
with this transmog controversy if you
want to hear the
best rant complaining about armor
synthesis
please check out the last word thai guy
travis is a good form
other than that um titanfall 2 at 120.
i've been rocking
through that backhand with the frame uh
frame price boost and um battlefield 4.
i took it back for that
and um been on my sports grind i saw
i've been yeah mlv the show
i tried the little road to october mode
and um nba 2k
i kind of got the fever with my players
so i just been in that bag
so um real quick on a different note i
just want to send some love to our boy
uh sinister x2 y'all know him
he's channel five he's clan most you
guys have played with him when you play
with the lord you always play with
sinister or
we're running you through a race
sinister's the one him and attic are the
ones running the show so
your condolences to his family and his
dad and grandma so you know they're
going through it please send some love
to our boy y'all guys know him he's in
this chat right now
brother we know you're going through it
and we just wanted to send some love to
you
so that's what we got solve real quick
you want to get a couple of super chats
down then we'll get straight into
the paris talk uh sure so we got a big
cloud gaming five dollar super chat
let's go ilp
thank you sir then we have michael aka
best styles finest two dollar super chat
king was right 23 million game pass
subscribers
i believe king says 25 but no no okay
i can answer your question really
quickly um 23 is
uh the show enough number uh 25
is uh you know those y'all be talking
about that one dollar thing
okay oh no i i perfect i feel that they
would count that one dollar thing
no they did count but um time on the
numbers
[Laughter]
say less yes god bless let's go akw
five pound super chat what's up lords
the wife is listening to the show for
the first time
thanks for the pass for the past year
you guys are great keep
up the great work the book of acts
then we have the flame two dollars super
chat can't wait the full show sirs
near calls me i can't watch the full
show sir neither calls me okay
then we have dirt griggity with this 5
super chat that's my dude that's the
dude what's up fellas great to see paris
on looking forward to the show
then we have gerald mack five dollars if
you chat shout out to lord
kingstradamus for the gp with the game
pass prophecy
then we have lord brap with the five
dollars
salute laura's great guest and going to
be an awesome show as always yeah big
shout out to crossfire and mooch and
everybody was on the panel the other day
i was on their friday fantastic show
thank you guys he had a good show
yesterday absolutely
absolutely then we have eagles fan 76
with the 2.000 chat
my favorite show salute to the lords and
addict
i thought gamertag radio was your
favorite brother there you go
you don't think i don't pay attention oh
you got you got him out here
i appreciate it slow-mo you started this
nonsense
though oh yeah we have more you want me
to go yeah let's just get it
so it's like three or four but i'll help
you out i see no i got them i got them i
got we got uh dj birdle
dos with the five dollars we chat lord
paris in the building the lord's day
gonna be
fired sir slow mo back slap with the
five dollars of a chat
afternoon gentlemen and addict
we need to link up on outrider's been
bringing ct-15 to
its knees absolutely yeah bring yourself
over here man yeah yeah cross-play pc
and xbox you can do it
yeah wait let me get one away man wanna
win dragon tv
fight our super chat good afternoon
lords yo you guys are awesome and your
undying support for me is real my
brothers are real ones facts
let me point out that that is how you
address the entire panel
uh he had a show yesterday check him out
on saturdays
at 7 00 p.m please dragons sir
i'm trying to i'm trying to figure out
my way to get on there we're doing that
okay
fast back with the two dollar super chat
iron lords a great gaming sunday it is
yes it is sir
then eagles fan 76 with the two dollar
super chat titanfall 2 120 fps
sorry utcs tv shaving again here we go
so speaking of cease and desist uh
rio kelly jesus
king stop hyping up xbox they got no
games
i don't worry about that because
yesterday whoa
baby came back to me i am so happy
that i can put this with my retro gaming
all these wonderful games oh
beautiful dude let's get up
cracking two dollars we chat have a
great show guys iop is my sunday
church fantastic sir ladies and gents
well that will be the end of super chat
for the time being because we have paris
on a limited time so
uh we appreciate all your super chats
but we'll read them later on in the show
thank you so much you could blame my
wife for that she
got to this time and then we got started
i i know so now that we got into all the
lords we play against business
i want to focus on lord paris his video
game system history
his amazing ascension within the games
industry and of course what led him to
the iconic game attack radio and kind of
funny x cast so lord paris let's start
from the very beginning what was some of
the first video game system you had and
what got you into gaming
all right before i get into that i have
to give you cognito a shout you were
fantastic on xcast
this week and uh it was it was like you
were
just a natural co-host on the show man
you did great i i loved it i loved
like we're about to talk about school i
love that you brought the old school in
there too man because that's what we
love to do shout out to that
oh and one last thing destiny 2 transmog
i hate it
it's a we always got to remember it's a
business first
they got to tweak this i get they're
trying to get their paper
but they got to tweet i agree i had this
conversation right there that's where i
feel the motivation is we'll continue so
you're absolutely yeah yeah
sorry sorry so so so where i start i'm
old so
i remember from the original original
like not even the atari 2600 i'm talking
the sears
knock-off hundreds oh yeah yeah when i
first started playing but
yeah man stuff back then you know combat
and
um adventure and obviously
also did you have in television did you
have colecovision
where where did where was your base
where where was your baby it was atari
it was a target
okay my buddy had the coleco vision
right
i used to go to his house i remember he
had like smurf yes
so so that was my early roots man and
then obviously the arcades dude right i
mean that was
that was my thing like it was a saturday
tradition
um i would get i have to say the whole
thing i have to get on the 26th bus
to downtown saint pete you get to
transfer downtown and hop
on to 36. go to tyrone square mall i
have 10 dollars
i have 10 worth of quarters i go to
aladdin's aladdin's arcade and i'm in
there all day and i'm just playing all
the games in there all day
that was kind of my origins but then
from there man um
christmas 85 i mean that was my red
rider bb gun moment my mom got me the
nes
uh deluxe set with rob the robot john
with the gyro yeah the whole complete
set there we go
but anyone that had robbed the robot you
didn't use robert the robot
you cheated yeah but but then you
use them once at least right you set up
the whole thing you set it up and you
realize
wait this sucks
they lied to me so so that and then
obviously um
you know i got super mario brothers a
little after that and then that was just
transformative yeah right because you
know obviously
to this day still one of the greatest
platformers ever made and
obviously iterated on that i think super
mario bros 3 my personal
greatest game ever personally but um but
yeah just obviously all the stuff with
the nes
zelda metroid just just everything in
that you know in in the uh mids ladies
like i even said on xcast
uh me and my buddies we used to do those
tecmo bowl tournaments every weekend
that's what it was all about just
completely changed the game for me as
far as sports games go
but you know obviously did that and you
know super nes comes out
genesis all that stuff um and then just
kind of flash forward
where were you though were you a genesis
kid or were you i don't know i was
to play sonic and ultra beasts and all
all that stuff right but yeah i was
i was a nintendo game any of your
friends had a turbo graphics
oh yeah yeah sponsored hey look box
adventure only game ever played on there
nothing else
yeah yeah all right so so yeah so that
was all the all the 90 stuff
and then uh i guess this kind of
transitions into
you know me getting into content
creation so i
forged a registration in 2001
because because i work in technology i
work in i.t so the company i work for i
made it seem like it had uh
something to do with consumer
electronics so i forged an application
registration
to get an exhibitor badge into e3 2001.
yeah yeah and i was going i was going as
a nintendo guy
right i ain't kidding about playstation
or xbox internet stuff i was going
because the gamecube was coming out
luigi's mansion and restaurant new zelda
all that stuff i wanted to see
that luigi's mansion was a clown but
went for that
i remember seeing you know i knew the
xbox was coming out i remember going by
the xbox booth
and they had it it was i forget which
unreal it was it was unreal tournament
whatever they were doing but
they had halo and i'll never forget this
i even posted pictures online they're on
social media
where i'm at that booth in 0-1 and i saw
halo
and i played it and i go man this thing
is buggy this is this xbox thing ain't
gonna
never work and literally dismissed it i
go this
microsoft crazy this this ain't gonna
never work completely dismissed
now flash forward you know the xbox and
the gamecube are about to come out
and i i was at work and i had to go to
comp usa for some dumb reason i don't
even remember why
remember that yeah you're taking us back
brother
we we're there together don't worry
about it
you're there
i'm looking at his screen you're
automatically excluded i have no
idea even remotely with that story i
can't okay continue
just pretend it's like a raggedy best
buy in youtube okay
okay so it's a regular best buy all
right all right anyways i had to go to
comp usa and it was like you know
mid afternoon or something and i
remember i drove up and i forgot it was
the launch day for the xbox
and i walk up and i see these people
stand outside oh dale y'all standing out
here for
like the xbox is coming out i was like
that thing and then i walked in
and it just i literally walked in cut
everybody in line
and i was like well i'm here screw it i
might as well pick it up so i bought it
right then and there
then i'm like i need games so i got did
you get dead or alive three
and i picked up halo even though i
didn't think anything of halo
whatever yo i didn't play halo for
probably a month until after i had the
xbox
back up back so i had all right so based
on your impression this
impression at e3 you sat with
you sat on it like okay i'll get to it
alive is the real launch game exactly
even seeing reviews because i know
reviews were out by that time like
they yeah it's the early it's the early
two years earlier
there was no internet like that yeah
yeah yeah you know you had to search
anyway all right so i know what you're
saying because when you went to the
shows back then e3 was about
uh you know developers and and and
people actually making
videos it really wasn't about uh having
people play
and all that other stuff it was really
selling a product it was consumer like
the ces show
so what you what you play was an early
build or something that they really
didn't care for the public to see they
just wanted to see developers to see
that right they had the legit booth i
mean you had other people there to play
but
yeah i i walked away from it very
unimpressed i was just like
because again i don't i didn't
understand back then how it works now
where
these are already bills i'm thinking
that's the game right
so i'm like who wants to play this this
is terrible
but uh but yeah i sat on it for about a
month and then for whatever
because again i'm in the gamecube i'm in
nintendo that's all i really cared about
and uh i was like all right let me let
me play this thing i own it and yo
i sat down and went through that that
campaign blood you know what
you know obviously multiplayer all that
stuff and
it just it was like revolutionary
because you know i remember on the
nintendo 64 golden eye perfect dark
stuff like that that was all great
but halo took it to a new level just
with with the duke controller and
everything yeah and absolutely
oh my god what was your aha moment and
and halo when when you looked at it and
said oh we might be on or something
truth and consequences
that was it that was it that's when i
knew this is something different i've
never
played a game like this a shooter game
like this that's when i knew it was
different
yeah it's absolutely right that was huge
for me it was two things one king i
can't remember remember the the duke
controller had the
camera buttons the blasters so for me
the first aha moment was you hit that
and the light would come on
the flashlight so whatever light source
or whatever i was like blown away by
that right when i first saw
that flashlight because there's a dark
area you're going to tell you to hit the
light button yeah when i
first saw that and i'm a pc dude from
back then you know we all had uh voodoo
cards and all that other stuff and i saw
that light
i said uh oh here we go here we go
second
was enemy ai yes because
i remember it was the next level yeah
the little grunts or whatever
you wrote a grenade and they went out
there way too scattered
and scattered and they would take
positions on you and i'm like yo this is
when he was talking and
[Music]
so from there i mean because remember
xbox live wasn't out at that
point right yo i used to hop on x-link
kai
playing multiplayer with people that you
know obviously you could do the local
lan parties but you want to play with
other people that was
the way we used to do it and then
obviously a year later xbox
live came out i got in the alpha for
xbox live
and i i've just i've just been on it
ever since and
yeah dude i remember playing ghost recon
yes back in the day
yeah yeah all that stuff and then you
know obviously nfl 2k was it 2k1 or 2k2
at that point
but that cemented me and and the whole
console online community you want to
play these games together
kind of stuff and then moving forward a
few years like oh
i used to email major nelson email him
talk about it and he
and he would respond on email because
that's how early all this stuff was that
nobody knew
you know what they were doing back then
so i would still go to e3 every year
during that point and
obviously you had playstation 2 and
gamecube xbox stuff
um and then we get to o5 that's when
danny pena started gamertag radio
and i used to listen to gamers because
he used to spam the team xbox forms
all the time come listen my show come
this in my show
and then he got to scoop when they were
bringing out the 360
where he got the pms clan on because
they had taped it early in hollywood
the 360 revealed and they were part of
it and they got to play perfect dark
zero and all that
somehow some way he hustled so he got
them on the show
and he released it and microsoft made
him take it down but i heard it
yo this is wild this is crazy and so it
was him and then there was another show
called dreamstation.cc
okay and uh another good friend of mine
chris palladino i used to listen to
those shows all the time back in 0.5
and then i remember one day now we're i
think we're no six at this point but
then i remember one day i'm watching
whatever video
and both these mofos are up in seattle
at a lord of the rings event for xbox
and look i'm not gonna lie
i saw that and i go yo and i remember i
was telling my my buddy at the time i
was like yo
you get to go to ex get to go to england
i was like
i want to do this too so this is what i
did i emailed both of them
hey cause me my buddy were like we're
gonna start our own podcast it was
called the old school game it's terrible
absolutely old school yeah yeah
so i emailed danny and i emailed chris
and i'm like hey we we started this new
podcast
we're trying to get tips like what do
you need to do all that kind of stuff so
chris
actually hit me back right away and i'll
never forget this and this is
and i'll talk about this later but it
was a saturday morning
he literally hits me up on skype and he
walked me through hey here's what you
need to record his kind of mike's unit
like he walked me through everything
beautiful
didn't have to he didn't even have to
respond he didn't have to do that
and then three weeks later danny
basically did the same thing because he
was out on vacation or whatever it was
but anyways
to keep short and sweet they were two
early mentors from me so then
that led me starting uncle gamer radio
and i did uncle gamer radio
from june of 06 until october of 2011
and during this time period danny and i
became really good friends
chris wind up working for xbox and
he again because there's a lot of luck
in all this stuff right so
so even before i get to the chris thing
so i started game attack radio 106.
i won a contest to go to the gears of
war
launch event in hollywood so i went
and just everything's terrible the audio
from everything's terrible i
sucked as a podcaster back then but i
met luke smith at that event
wow and that's when he was at one up so
this is before he was at bungie or in
that stuff right
and we were yeah we were drinking and
having a good time the whole thing so we
became cool
out of that and then flash forward
beyond that because i'll get to that
later
but beyond that i uh chris palladino
he's at
xbox he invited me to the crackdown
event that they had in early 07.
yo i had no business being there i know
what i was doing
and that kind of got my foot in the door
with xbox i yo i got to meet major
nelson i got to see xbox live i could do
all this stuff back then
that then led to me becoming an xbox mvp
so which kind of gave me more access
into stuff that xbox was doing and all
that back in those early days
now meantime danny and i have become
friends at this point like really good
friends
right and you know he would he would
help you know he would help me he would
always
mentor me and tell me yo you got to get
out your house you got to do this you
got to do that
kind of thing so we basically became
collaborators
during this time and always friends
always helping each other out like i got
an interview with ken levine for
bioshock before bioshock came out
again i don't know how i was doing this
stuff back then because i didn't know
nobody but i somehow hustled my way into
an interview with ken levine
and i remember danny gave me the great
advice he was like yo when you put this
out you have to say it's exclusive
because nobody else has this as a
podcast you got to do that so
i did that yeah put it out it wound up
being really good
i got really cool with people at 2k got
early access to bioshock at the time all
this stuff is happening during this time
again dan and i are really good friends
he's constantly mentoring me helping me
out
so another milestone like you brought a
mass effect 2 at one point so again
it's it's about relationships it's the
whole point i'm trying to make here
i had met a pr person
over the years so then by the time 2010
came up this pr person was working at ea
okay and she got me access to casey
hudson
let's go yeah before mass effect 2 came
out
i ain't gonna lie to this date best
interview i've ever done in my life
because i researched that was cherished
i knew everything about about it had
this conversation with casey
and i never forget it it kind of went
viral in the in the uh
bioware community because i remember the
forums blew up said they loved it and
all that kind of stuff
but all that happened because you're
establishing those relationships over
the years right
you treat people with respect you know
it's it's a two-way street with respect
and all that kind of stuff right you
never dismiss
someone because they're in one position
today because you don't even know what
they're going to be tomorrow
exactly so the whole point i'm making on
that is we do all that
um my my co-host on uncle gamer wound up
getting a job at ea
um in uh in 2011 and then i was like you
know what i'm only doing this because
it's fun i've already seen and done so
many great things in the industry i'm
good i retire i'm done
but i'm still friends with danny at this
point pete and all that we're all we're
friends we're just friends legit friends
so
bioshock infinite comes out in 2013.
big fan of that again the kind of legacy
with ken levine and stuff right so
i just would love the game right danny
was like hey
you should come on gtr and talk about it
right okay
i'll come on wind up coming on people
that was listening really liked when i
was on
and kind of was like yo you should get
paris come on more blah blah blah blah
so so so then pete reaches out to me and
goes
yo you should come on full time and i
was like i don't know about that
was you retired from podcasting done i
had stopped in like i said i stopped in
october of 2011.
this is march of 2013 at this point
gotcha so i was out
i was you know you got burnt out or was
it
or was it you know two all right because
you know from what i'm hearing is you
was going to a lot of shows you had a
lot of money
yeah yeah you're doing a lot of things
you put out the videos and stuff like
that and you said you reached a high
point
and i want to know if did you reach that
burnout point that you had to recharge
your batteries
or what no no it wasn't a burnout thing
it was
because i still live by this philosophy
it wasn't fun because again my co-host
there we go he was in the industry at
this point so i was like bringing in
other people
and it wasn't a good fit and i didn't
really want to do it by myself
and i was looking at it as yo i've
already
yo i've traveled the world at this point
seeing i'm like i'm good
i can walk away from this kind of stuff
so i just walked away but obviously i
still love gaming
so so when you know pete made that danny
pete made the offer at first i was
hesitant like look
i come home when i can i don't know
right oh i've been full time ever since
i just became a part of gtr and
obviously everything we've done with gtr
since 2013 like we actually the year
after that
danny and i got to interview phil
spencer i was just about to stop you
brother because we
go we go so we gotta we gotta set this
up bro this is
iconic talk right now because for me
shout out to danny shout out to peter
you guys have been grinding and doing it
so long you hit the conventions you're
going out you're putting your groundwork
and i don't want to
you know minimize that but like to see
that and to see the level of stature of
people that you continue to get on the
show and and all of the things that you
broke on game
the gtr was iconic but i want to lead
you now to this
moment where you guys get phil spencer
excuse me uh king king
dominance that's really expensive
correct
but at this time at this time he was
talking to phil spencer you wasn't
talking to phil dominance maximum really
so let me let me say it is because i
want to be crystal clear to everyone
that's watching and listening to this
right now
everything i've done in in in the gaming
industry that's why i mentioned danny
and chris at the top i owe it to them
and and even more
you know even beyond those early days
danny i'm not doing this without danny
payne
that's that's just one of the things
and that's why i i'll i'll just say it
right here you know i don't care where
you get at in the industry
always try to pay it forward right
always try to bring the next people up
that's just that's just how it works
because if he didn't respond if him and
chris didn't respond to me on email and
they didn't have to
they did it because they wanted to i'm
not here right and then even beyond that
you still got to put in the work and all
the effort that goes along with that but
anyways going back to what you're saying
so
danny is the one he wrote a letter to
don matrick
after the 2013 fiasco with the xbox one
basically like you ain't listening to
the community you need to talk to us
blah blah blah obviously that went
unanswered
but but that letter went around
internally inside of microsoft and and
we're convinced because of that
phil spencer agreed to do an interview
with us at e3 2014 because now at this
point he's taking over he's still
less than a year on the job that's
correct and um
yo it was great it's funny because you
know seeing phil now compared to phil
back then it's the same dude which
which is it was a great thing about him
right because i remember you know we're
all nervous like oh
that's the big one yo he walks in i
think it was ori
was in the meeting room we're in and
danny's playing it and phil walks in he
was like put my controller down
and we're like oh but it was a great
conversation we had when him
and um and i was bluntly honest with him
i was like i don't like connect i don't
know why you put it in there that that
whole thing but that kind of sets the
table for us
with our relationship with xbox and
everything that that's been happening
since but
like like you're saying man it's it's
that hustle
of don't be afraid to get outside your
comfort zone don't be afraid to go out
meet people so i'll tell the bonnie ross
story really quick let's go
so the year after that 2015 master chief
collection
is is about to come out right so they're
doing you know behind closed doors
meetings and all that kind of stuff
and bonnie ross and someone else from
343 is doing behind closed door thing
for the master chief collection
me and danny are sitting in there danny
leans over to me hey
after this is done should we interview
bonnie ross absolutely
sounds like a great idea in other words
danny's saying he's going to do it all
right
come out he gets done he gets bonnie
over everybody's sitting there waiting
i'm off to the side chilling yeah he
looks at me he goes
paris i throw i can't
i was like deer in the headlight like oh
yo in my head full panic to me to me
because i've never listened to it i
refuse to listen
i i know what to say i didn't know what
to do i probably talked 10
000 miles an hour that interview was
probably 30 seconds long i don't know
all i did was hit the eject button but i
say this to say this
2016 red e3 they're having an xbox it
was almost like the fan fest stuff you
do now right
bonnie ross and kiki wolf killer there
and it's me danny and pete and we go
over we're talking to him casually in a
conversation
so i bring it up to her i go yo last
year you probably remember this i met
you i go i panicked in my head
whatever and we're all laughing and then
she says to me and and this has stuck
with me since let's go
i was just as nervous as you probably
was doing that interview
yeah right and then i'm i'm telling you
it was it was a moment that
really everything clicked and came into
focus for me i'm like wait a minute
these are just people yeah they're just
people like me
okay she's in this position whatever but
the end of the day she's she got the
same insecurities and fears and all that
stuff that i do right
they're just people and i'm telling you
since that moment light switch went on
i just treat every you just treat
everyone the same
you get jitters and all that kind of
stuff i'm never nervous anymore
because of that and and i try to pass
that advice along to people
just treat people the way that you want
to be treated going to these interviews
i don't care what position they're in
they're just people man so it's like
flash forward all the way till last year
we interviewed phil spencer again
look right literally right before the
pandemic started and um
you know that's how we treated it man
and we had a great conversation with him
just about the future plans with the
series x and i remember i was asking
about vr
and their plans in japan and and all
that kind of stuff and um
that because i know you're going to ask
the question about you know the my
quote-unquote ascension and their
gaming or whatever but that kind of
kicked it off i think
because of my question my question to
you right
because i'm hearing all the xbox talk
and
a nintendo dude growing up yeah yeah
yeah right
and you went to this e3 you forged your
way in
right and um you know and you just
happenstance to xbox xbox's happenstance
like you walked in the store
yeah let me get it you know if this is
that wasn't on your radar
no right your ideal goal was nintendo
have you
ever got any nintendo interviews or
something like that
in that area that you were you know
seeking like speaking of reggie fisa may
or or something like that because i
think to me i think reggie is the most
gangsta scene
to be honest that's just my opinion of
it because i make little scenarios in my
head
but my question to you have you gotten
any interviews with any nintendo people
because this is this is your heart this
is your soul
this is the stuff that you grew up on
and you fanboy on this point
before the microsoft stuff any nintendo
stuff
no and then i'll explain why so we did
get reggie
uh earlier this year i actually
unfortunately couldn't be on it but
again he's not in nintendo at this point
um i have met and conversed with
shigeru miyamoto which i almost passed
that out when i had
as far as like official interview we've
done i've gotten reviewed
review code and stuff like that from
nintendo but this is the point i'll
i'll make here because because i i look
i know there's various people out there
that
may or may not like my opinions and
think i have biases
certain things i completely agree
i probably talked so much xbox xbox in
those early days
um they were very community focused and
and they helped get me to where i am
that's just a god honest truth
and they have been very open to doing
interviews with with some of their top
people things like that
the truth is this nintendo and
playstation have not
been that open when it comes to stuff
like that and it's not a thing of oh i
hate playstation
or anything like that right it's true
look dishonesty we want content
same here if you want to give us content
we're going to take it trust me
right playstation's got a lot better i
have a great working relationship with
playstation now but back then absolutely
not
you know and nintendo's still that way
but
i still love nintendo i still say you
know some of the great
again i say that nintendo is the
greatest developer in the world because
they're always innovative and they
always take risks and they always do
things the other two
won't yes that's why you have the switch
that's why we have a wireless controller
that's why we have rumble that's why you
have all these things yeah that's why
you got labo
yeah yeah shout out to the cardboard
yeah
they're willing to take those ways so so
yeah it's it's just a thing that we've
just not had the opportunities we would
love them okay i'll get you yeah
question real quick yeah i i really had
to ask that question because it was in
my head
no i'm not muted stop talking look i'm
trying to
i'm interrupting okay oh yeah ips is
linked i wanted to
to go in all uh double down on like you
said like paris about being
you know kind of nervous and in a
setting that you're not comfortable with
right i wouldn't there is one particular
thing in iop i will never forget we was
in a line for bleeding edge and
regardless how you feel about bleeding
we're sitting there in
in the the the the person in charge of
bleeding
like we snatched this chick in the mid
and made stroll it's just like it was
he was like yo that's the header you
need to edit for her now so be a song
and that was one of the moments so we
were sitting there lying he's just like
yeah sure so we're next in line like
we're about to come up
and she's like well you guys are about
to go and he's like no they can they can
go past
us we literally had half of the show
we had half the people like that
obviously they had like the little line
made with uh those red velvet uh
ropes or whatever they're called yeah so
we have half the team on
one side half team on the other side and
we're trying to do this we're trying to
let the
the people go through in in a high
planner
yeah it was like it was definitely one
of those things where it's like
you had to move at the last minute
absolutely and and
not the country just that it's that you
know when paris is talking about like
his body raw situation it reminds me
of shout out to log that if they're in
the building um platinum games we were
able to secure yes
and having these two legends you know
what i said
and the the translator and it's just
like i've never done anything like this
before
but it was such an opportunity i was
like i cannot miss this
and i have to try my best to make this
work you know
you do you remember that time thanos
pulled me over to the side and was like
listen you want to interview uh
nina christian yes for the head of ninja
theory
and this was act fan fest i'm by myself
i don't do interviews so i'm doing i'm
holding the camera i'm doing the
interview
and i'm nervous as hell but i'm talking
to her that yeah fan fest and i get the
interview this is when
uh phil dominance maximum is really
expensive
at that time yeah no he wasn't realist
at that time he was still dominant
as gary wooda says he's the he's the
dark lord
[Laughter]
he was climbing
so at that point this is when they
acquired a ninja theory
the following year i saw her and every
time larry herb sees me he yells out
what's up bro
bronx yeah i love larry hurt um so i saw
her she was walking through the crowd
uh and i got a chance to speak to her
later on that night because we was at
fan fest
and i said y'all saw you walking through
the crowd because now we already have a
conversation we already know each other
i saw you walking through a crowd you
were soaking it up she was like no i
made the wrong mistake i walked the
wrong way
and now i'm walking through the crowd so
i said you know that's the honesty thing
but
she stuck around and like you said these
people
that we hold in such high regard are
people people
yeah you know and she's been such a
wonderful nice person
that we tried we distance ourselves from
those people but they're not we we are
the same
another question paris uh you mentioned
that you have you have a really good
relationship with playstation
um so the question i have for you is
like have you gotten any sense as to why
they sort of shifted away from having
like
like forward-facing faces much like in
the way that xbox is doing because we
don't we don't have a jack trenton
anymore we don't have a shuha yoshida
is there any indication that you've
gotten as to why they've moved away from
that
because it works so well for them in the
ps4 generation yeah none and and i'm i'm
with you on that i think if there was
one thing about
let me be clear about this about
playstation i know there's been a lot of
doom and gloom and
skies falling with them yo they're going
to be fine they're going to be fine
all these games everyone's going to go
crazy on them they're going to be fine
but if i had one criticism of it is yeah
where's adam boyce you know where's the
g.o like you're saying you should
like where's that face that's right one
thing
yeah okay all right and they're over
confident oh yeah and that's that's
gonna get them
knocked out i disagree on that but i
don't think i don't i don't say it to
um like to elicit a response or whatever
because like this this part
is for you right we can we could talk
all this other stuff about it but
i don't because i want to know about
pirates yeah
[Laughter]
i just simply say the rapid thing on on
playstation yeah i mean i
i don't know and i i if i had a critique
they it'd be nice if they did have a
more public face that people can relate
to
and and points toward point things
towards but i mean just just going back
to me i
get like i said with the phil spencer
thing that happened early last year
that kind of kicked off um with all this
crazy stuff that's been happening in the
last year i mean obviously the cyberpunk
stuff
happened even before that you know when
that that went viral and obviously like
look we know last year the chair
but unfortunately and i and i hate i
hate to say it this way but it but it's
kind of true
um the death of george floyd last year
in a in an unfortunate way did help me
because it brought more awareness to
black creators
in in this space it it opened some doors
for people to to want to give people
more opportunity so shout out to ryan
mccaffrey
first and foremost i know cognito you've
been on there um
i always ride with that dude because
he it was dumb luck one day he just
needed someone to come on
and it wind up being me and him doing uh
unlocked one day and i almost said no
i almost said no ironically no but i
went on him and i just one-on-one did
this thing
and there was a great reception from
that led to me doing more things with
ign over the summer
um greg miller over kind of funny had me
come in and
do an episode with blessing which went
really well
shout out to alana pierce because when
they started
she's the one that was like you got to
get paris on here i'm going to get paris
on here so
i came on co-hosted a couple times
feedback on that was really good which
then when she left
led to the to the full-time position
stuff but um
yeah it's just it's just been crazy you
know over the summer just getting
a lot a lot of different opportunities
like you know i hosted that night city
wire i hosted the ign
xbox showcase thing um obviously the
stuff i've done were kind of funny and
everything
um i've been able to branch even outside
the game and i've been doing some stuff
with new rock stars
you know with some of the mcu stuff and
um you know nvidia's
i've done some sponsor stuff with nvidia
as well um
yeah i mean i mean it's been it's been
cool and you know i'm very appreciative
and i'm always very humble of that and
and i know
i know some people um see those
opportunities
ah you sold out you did this you did
that that's like brad it ain't about
selling out it's about
i'm always hustling yes if you got an
opportunity look let me put it this way
if an opportunity comes your way right
what would you do
and the ones that say no i wouldn't take
it your line
that's just a god honest truth because
of course you want to take advantage of
these opportunities of course
you know we're in this whole content
creation biz and you know we want to get
access to things
and sorry but marketing is a part of it
so
so i know you wanted you were talking
about the cyberpunk thing yeah cd
projekt red
has sent me things yes xbox has sent me
things playstation has sent me things
it's a part of it man yeah i mean but
but the one thing whether people want to
believe me or not
my opinion is my opinion if something's
great i'ma tell you it's great if
something sucks
i'm gonna tell you it sucks as an
example when xbox
decided to try and pull the okie doke oh
we're gonna charge you 120
for xbox live gold because secretly we
want to push everyone towards game
passes like come on this is ridiculous
you can't do that and they change oh go
ahead no i was going to say two quick
questions because
you're expounding on so many amazing
points and
the two things is one the joke because i
see the chair in the back because the
reuben is
you you're an illuminati now paris they
see it
that you signed the contract anybody
with the yellow chair
is in so i just need to go ahead
[Laughter]
did you make a blood pack did you make
it
i'll tell you i'll tell you this because
i told you this offline than when we
were doing x cash
i purposely put that make sure you
travel
that's right because i know it makes
people mad because to me it's the
dumbest freaking thing in the world to
be mad over a yellow chair oh you got a
chair so you sold out
come on dummy really it's like a chair
is a chair
it's like no go ahead no
i tell people all the time you know uh
because they tell them they call me
captain game pass yeah yeah right
and and i tell them listen i'm brought
and sold all right
yeah don't believe anything i say let me
tell you i am brought and so
shout out to aaron greenberg and i say
it every day all day you know so
um and and and they know why but
again if if you go to these events and
stuff is offered to you or
you get an email and they say hey we're
gonna send you a review copy or we're
gonna do this so we're gonna do this
you're in this business to do that right
right now your opinion afterwards and
you don't want to be disparaging or rude
because they want everybody to either be
rude
either hate something or love it all the
way and if you're in the middle they
think you sold out
you know so and that's not how it goes
you could be in the middle and lukewarm
on certain things and
point out flaws and point out positives
and that can happen
even if you got a review copy right so
if anybody feels of
any weight and i tell them ahead of time
i've been brought and sold with certain
stuff when it comes my way for free
i'm gonna let you know ahead of time we
all have biases with certain things yeah
the other day like paris is saying you
know it's his
job to give his honest opinion on
something it
serves no purpose for anyone to be
frauding on something
you know because you're not doing
yourself this search you're not doing a
community
service so one thing i respect is like
you said when there's times when both
xbox and playstation do things that
we don't like and i've seen you on the
front lines
very vocal this is not it you know like
you said in the xbox live thing i just
want to
i'm gonna get you so i just want to ask
one other question because um the thing
i want to commend you is is in my
opinion like i said your grind
the work ethic you know the hustle you
know
a lot of us in the community are
extremely proud of you you know and
and seeing as a content creator of color
right seeing
what the work you put in so my question
i have is
for our brothers who may be frustrated
they're working really hard they're
really trying you know what i mean
and that maybe their voice is not heard
what advice may you give to them to say
okay
keep your head up or to keep pushing
forward to try to get them
you know mentally out of the doldrum of
like man i'm really trying but i don't
seem to be getting
any opportunity um the thing that i
always say on this is first and foremost
do it because it's fun do this because
you love to do it
um stop paying attention to the numbers
because it will drive you absolutely
insane because
here's here's the truth of the matter
when you first start out i don't care
what kind of content is you're doing
the only people that's going to be
listening to it is you your mama and
maybe young tv
in fact we was bad when our friends
wasn't in the chat continue right
but but you know you you have to be
consistent
with whatever it is you're doing you
obviously got to put in the work behind
it but
have patience be consistent with it
again i know we're in the pandemic right
now but once we're out of it
go to events even if they're local
events if you can't go to a comic con
or pax or whatever you've got to go to
that you got to put face to name
with a lot of this stuff you know what
i'm saying like again i talk about my
early days with this stuff like
i bring up the luke smith thing that i
talked about at the beginning
luke and i met before he was the whole
creator thing of destiny and all that
kind of stuff but
we established that relationship early
on it's not like he's my best friend and
we talking every day but
you know we might have a conversation
here and there and you know obviously
you know when i i see man an event you
know we have conversations but you're
establishing that relationship
and it's like i tell you anytime i see
him i go man
i'm so proud of you you've seen me where
you where you've gone and
the same things goes with your content
creation just because you've not
reached the point where you're getting
the yellow chair and people can be mad
at you
it doesn't mean that you're not gonna
get there one day right because
if you make great if you make dope
content it will get discovered
eventually but you got to put in the
work to help it along the way use social
media as
anyone follows me on twitter i am very
meticulous with what i tweet out and
what i talk about there is a method to
my madness
a lot of the times with the stuff that i
say do that
use that as a platform to reach and look
don't be spamming people and doing like
kind of crazy stuff
but do that get out there shake hands
kiss babies go try to
you know if you can't guest appear on
other people's shows or invite people to
your shows and all that kind of stuff
because you you never know that person
that you meet today where they're going
to be at tomorrow right
but it starts with you you you have to
stay consistent with it just because you
aren't seeing the success that you have
that you want today doesn't mean you're
not going to get it tomorrow so
if you're a streamer set up your
schedule let people know
when they can expect your content to
come out same as if you podcast
obviously like you guys do this stuff on
sunday i look i
already know mental note 10 a.m on a
sunday if it ain't football season night
friday you know what i'm saying so
that's a part of it man and here's the
most important thing of all
be yourself be who you are because the
one thing that i
always take pride in the way i'm talking
to you right now that's how you know i'm
the same i'm that same dude
when we meet in person it is no
different
i'm not the gimmick guy i don't pretend
to be a character and all this stuff
yeah well see i'm really not like that
it's like come on just be yourself i
gotta i gotta say paris
uh i i really appreciate you coming on
and addressing and addressing that
you get you get a lot of flack from
from uh you know from from the community
sometimes about like
what you said people assuming you've
sold out and this that and the next yeah
and to hear your you know the story
about your grind and your hustle
um again even today we had some people
in the chat that had to be sort of timed
out because they were being rude
and they were being rude because they
come in with presuppositions of who you
are and what you've
done and don't listen to your story and
if there's one thing that we try to
promote here it's like
everybody everybody has a voice that
needs to be heard and when you really
stop and listen to the stories
a lot of things you assume about people
are wrong
okay can i say can i say this real quick
along what you're saying so i'm actually
glad you said that because yeah i catch
i catch a lot of stuff online because
people only get half the story or they
don't actually
put in the actual worker research to get
the full story because
they want they want to be mad at you
i've learned that
trust me as i have chronicled grown in
popularity and awareness and all kind of
stuff
i forget who said that it might have
been joe rogan that said this but
the more popular you get the more haters
you're going to get it's just this is
how it works
because someone's always going to be
upset with something that you say or you
do
you can't worry about that stuff you
just got to be yourself absolutely i'm
myself
whether you think i sold out or not that
again that is literally why i keep that
chair in the background
because it's a you problem if it upsets
you it's not a me problem
because that's a very comfortable chair
sitting in this herman miller chair oh
it's
even more comfortable
you know what i'm saying are you wearing
your bo play portals too sir
but i got them right here
just like i got my playstation 5 right
here just like i got my series x right
here there you go
we got an expression they pocket watch
it bro
but but the reason the reason i bring
that up up is this like like again going
back to the
the silly chair thing like the cyberpunk
thing right
anyone that's mad at me did you take the
five
minutes to actually go see what i said
in my room
nope they didn't they didn't listen i
mean i literally leave it at that when i
see people say crazy stuff like that
did you actually do you actually consume
my content to see what i say or do you
see a picture i put on social media
correct and make and make judgment or
put your meme out or in his other stuff
come on man really it's like it's like
i'm a grown ass man with three kids
exactly you know
trying to make a living and it's like
this gaming stuff ain't how i make my
living this ain't where i make my bread
i don't know because he's brother
brother we aint brother i gotta get out
of it cause he's been waiting patiently
as ipsy
okay i wanna bring up the
okay first off i have like a list of
stuff because
[Music]
first thing like i remember i was in a
uh i was in a podcast where you came up
and they were talking about the chair
thing and i remember thinking
all right i remember i i shut them all
down because i was like okay
because i was like first off almost
everyone you know gets reviewed because
you just don't know it
uh some people don't even bring up the
fact they got the review of which is
illegal pretty much
the second offer like if you don't like
people because they're getting free
merchandise
almost every influencer that you like in
it whether it's nba
man they all get free stuff you gonna
hate them like i'm just like look like
you got that chair because you went to
these events you met the people
and then they liked you and they it's
not like everyone got a chair like
like they met because they didn't get a
chair and they might be
like i love how you brought up you know
going to the events
at the end of the day we tell people all
the time that helped us
tremendous yeah i'm always one of the
advocates that's like
i do feel like doors are intentionally
shut on people
and for the most part uh i i will say
that
the gaming industry is a definitely a
gatekeeping industry
in multiple avenues and it's almost
important like you gotta
sit there and try every key man if using
a horror movie you'd be dead
right you know i'm always one of those
people it's like
what else can you do to open these doors
and then you know you look around it's
like you know if you're not going to
events
which is the biggest door opener that
you could get to right
and what it is yep and shout out to king
cameras cameras everybody got us on
camera king got us with the shirts
yeah you got it director of iop um
a lot of things i do is bold and a
little bit different i don't look at
other people's podcast too much because
i don't want it to convolute my
thoughts going forward and i know you
can understand that stuff like that so
when you say you know you're checking
hair in there
because you're doing your thing you're
focused on your thing bringing your
brand up and stuff like that so
certain things i feel is definitely
needed
one you must be a man of the people so
when i'm out in california
going through the line not worrying
about playing video games
all week long i'm going through the line
handing out free iap
shirts and handing out cards and and
talking to people
and getting to know people not worrying
about can i play this game or can i do
this
and going to do these interviews even if
it's at the super bowl which is
you know california e3 and going to pax
going to the playoffs going to march
madness because i feel like pax is march
madness
and i'm going to each and every
developer is not one developer i don't
[ __ ] i hit every interview we do 75
interviews within that period of time
that we're there we're doing all the
content there
and i'm trying to get every game there i
have a formula on how we work
and the branding means a lot so when
somebody says oh
i love the logo oh i love how you're
doing this oh i love this is on
i take pride in that you know and you
have to put in the work
to get the results absolutely absolutely
you have to
finish and then we got it we're running
over yeah yeah it's like i said like you
know
going to these events you you open
yourself up to these people they put
a face to the name or the majority of
the the connections we have is because
we went to pax because we went to e3
it's just like let's be real here going
to these events is not cheap
at all whatsoever you know we have to
fly from the east coast to the west to
go to e3
you've done it three or four times and
it's just like you got to put in the
work
you know and it's like i said there are
a lot of scenarios where even you put in
the work you're just not getting any
visibility
and you know that that is definitely a
hard thing to face
but it's just like you got to get into
these communities you got to talk to
these people
head face to face you know you've got to
meet the community managers
and one thing i've always said like a
lot of the time
people are gatekeeping themselves
you're going on twitter you're saying
some crazy stuff
because you don't agree with what
it's like you think people you think
people don't see that
you think people don't see you flipping
out on a community magic because you
don't agree with something that
the company did you think that company
is going to want to work with you
anymore onto something
so on those exact lines if i could pass
along
any advice to anyone watching or listen
to this
the internet never forgets yes there's
an old saying you can't take pee out the
ocean
because this is real this is real
when you hop on social media and you act
in a damn fool
someone is watching that i promise you
and you might be acting a fool today
but then three years from now you've
quote unquote gotten your act together
and now you want to do this
those receipts will be pulled up
anyone look at how i look at what i
engage and disengage with
on twitter because i'm i'm not i'm not
going to sit here and argue with you
if i like playstation or not right go
ask go ask playstation if i like
playstation
that's not my problem i engage with
people that
are looking that are trying to succeed
that are trying to be motivated they're
trying to be positive you i'm not gonna
sit here and waste my time
engaging with negative people that are
simply trying to drag you down to their
level
yeah that's all that's all they're
trying to do it's like again if you're
trying to make it as a content creator
do not engage with this negativity
someone says your content sucks
say thank you very much and move on
oh sorry no no no no i go please go
ahead i would just say the crazy part is
like people feel like
you know oh they're attacking paris
because of because he got a chair
oh he he you can't trust his opinion on
cyberpunk it's like look
there's a difference between being
constructively criticizing a company
and bashing a company right and i feel
like most people want you to bash a
company they don't want you construct
a company they don't want you to give a
feedback that people can understand
because
nine times out of ten if you're being a
hundred percent with them
they're going to understand that and
they're going to take that to heart and
they're going to improve on that
but if you come out and be like this is
bull like you know say you flipped out
they've literally already you could
disagree you could not like something
but you got to be respectful it's how
you talk to people and like like parents
said you made
tremendous points again about the
receipts about everything you do again
even if you
had you know transformed yourself like
you said get your act together so to
speak
down the road these things will come
back to haunt you and people
will pull that up on your history so
that that yeah
trust me when i tell you you will be
shocked exactly okay
and who listens who sees what you say
and won't won't like won't reply won't
say nothing and then you'll be at an
event two years later
oh yeah i know you because you say that
well they did yeah
absolutely it's real talk you gotta move
i just wanna shout out
real quick because i know we run it i
get times limited the legendary
danny pena is in the chat so i had to
salute
you know what i'm saying your boys are
here man
oh and let me let me say again if you
didn't hear me before i'll say it again
cause
to everybody danny pena when we talk
this whole podcasting game this gaming
thing and all that
that is the og i am not here without
that dude
he started all this for all of us we're
not doing this without danny pena
because
he was the one that had the foresight
back in those early days
that hey there's something we could do
with this this gaming thing and
and when i say us i'm talking people of
color real talk because there is not
enough of us that are doing this right
now and that's
and that is why i support the iron lords
that is why
i sneak watch what is that football
season what is that for
that review when it's football season
we gotta focus i wanna at least get you
in for one topic sure sure
i know you could your time straight but
uh i got again let's do all the question
that we
asked yeah i'm getting curious
this is very contentious i need to know
lord paris's top five video games or
franchises of all time
yeah let's go let's go brother okay
super mario bros 3
man you man that's tough
yeah there's no order to this but super
mario brothers three mass effect two
whoa say it again
you're wrong
i'm conflicted of saying i'll just say
the legend of zelda
majority mass ocarina time combined yeah
okay so the franchise
yeah the french sword for attic no
kidding no no
okay well let's go right there okay no
there's no sky with sword but i see so
he did
it why did you why did you try to say
the franchise well he mentioned two
games
okay first of all he mentioned three
games that was one i mean you gotta
listen to the man
you're a game in a negative life
i'm not gonna say time on that he's
gonna attack me
the man told you to stop looking at the
headlines and feed the paragraph
he didn't say you won all right fair
defender we got those three
two more all right this one's going to
surprise you let's go yeah mega man two
okay okay
i have a hard time putting modern games
in it
i really do because again my legacy
my love again started back then so
that's that's why i kind of
i kind of lived back then man that fifth
one is tough for me because there's just
so many floating around in my head that
i i
i i want to say mm-hmm arcade games
yeah there we go
i mean but but look i i have love for
uncharted 2.
i have love for spider-man i have love
for god of war
you know i have love for for halo 3
as an example but and i'm kind of torn
between is it halo 2 or halo 3 which one
i think is my favorite you know what i'm
saying but
you know the original bioshock is
another one that comes to mind for me as
well
so i mean they're definitely so many but
yes
but zelda mario like i said mega man
those those are the ones that instantly
come to mind
when i think greatest games for me all
the time and uh our final question um
favorite console of all time and why
um yeah all did it make any generation
[Laughter]
remember the internet this is actually
easy i'm just not sure which one i
should lean on but
i'mma go nes okay okay but it could be
super nintendo as well
i i almost feel like they're equals but
nes
started it all for me i mean like i said
now we bring mike tyson's punch out in
there couldn't
couldn't get past super macho man
um yeah i'm gonna say nes yeah okay
so look time constraints so what we're
gonna do we'll skip poll
we'll we'll get super chats after let's
at least get powers for one time because
we got 15 more minutes with them
and i want to get at least one in so
attic this is yours i believe
um alleged contracts right that's what's
going on man
yeah you know my topic i want to talk
about people is
there was supposedly a
a contract with marketing that was
leaked off of
the resident evil marketing on terms of
sony and what capcom
them agreed to and it looks like in
there there's a little uh you know
uh we ain't want your stuff you're still
going to get for at least a year
after release which you know in
hindsight's not really a big deal but i
did want to bring it to because it looks
like
you know i said it a couple weeks ago i
you know i do feel like
sony's gonna start incorporating clauses
into their contracts to prevent stuff
from going to gamepass
and you know people are saying it's
anti-consumer i guess in a way it is but
it's like look if you expect sony just
to like oh you can have you
we marketing it you can put it on game
pass like it's not going to go work like
that
and i wanted to go to the ram like do
you guys think that you know
something like this if sony really goes
right to the floor with it you think it
could affect game pass in the long run
all right no doubt so let's get a little
paris said again like like like framed
it
this alleged this rumored contract you
know this legal thing as far as
exclusivity
parity and possibly um game pass being
um
potentially excluded if this document is
real right again
we do not know this for a fact so i
don't know if you got a chance to see
that
and okay cool dude you know what are
your thoughts on this type of thing
people blowing this up where you're at
with this fast
it's kind of like something i said
earlier you got to remember at the end
of the day this is the business right
when they're signing these deals and
they're doing all that kind of stuff
they're going to put clauses in
in like this because look they're trying
to get you to go
buy the game on their platform and not
go somewhere else to buy it right that's
the whole point of making
these deals and these partnerships so
while us the consumer can look at it
and go yeah this is terrible why are
they doing this the
i don't like this this is anti-consumer
blah blah blah blah they're looking at
it as
i'm trying to make money man i mean
look as a gamer of course look i think
everything should be on game pass
because i think game pass is the
greatest value in game and i know people
get mad when i say that but it's true
but i could totally understand why sony
would look at something like that and go
hey we'll make this deal
but uh no you're not allowed to talk to
microsoft and put this thing
on game pass it has to be here for
whatever
agreed upon time that they come to i
like i say i get it
right because there's this business at
the end of the day do i like it
absolutely not i think i think it's a
terrible thing but i could totally
understand i could
and i guess what i'm saying is i could
totally get that as real right this is
what i'm saying
yeah lord solve your thoughts on this
potential or
a legit deal contract i mean listen
obvious it just seems looking at it it
seems that it's a parody thing right
like to make sure listen
yeah these guys aren't going to get
features
and and modes and things of that nature
that we aren't going to get
right that that's the standard that's
standard business practice especially
when you have a marketing deal
so that's something like you know it's
just the way people interpret the
language right
and if you were to interpret it as sony
is doing things to prevent things from
going to game pass
you know what good on them yeah you know
why
because all's fair and loving war what
you're supposed to do
and phil spencer just took your
franchise
and and went to your front phil dominus
maximus
aurelius thank you sir
you got to come up with a sarah aka the
dark lord
yeah yes he just took your franchise
walked to your front porch and took the
steaming hot one right on the
on your front porch and and smiled
and smiled and said i got your game yes
so
you do what you have to do to compete
and if they don't have a direct account
exactly it is one of those things like
you have you do what you have to do to
compete if
if it is the case that there's something
in there that means that you know
they don't it doesn't go to game pass
for a year or six months or whatever
good on them they do what they have to
do because i they're not in a position
to directly counter punch game pass they
have to do what they've been doing
second party deals third party
exclusivity but they have with with two
square index titles now
um they're gonna keep doing this sort of
stuff so if you think it's an
anti-consumer uh you're in for a ride
this this generation because yeah for
sure so
again good on them do what you got to do
and and microsoft is going to do what
they have to do exactly lord king your
thoughts on this sir
okay first a lot of people thought that
i would be on a different side of this
sony's doing this crazy first of all i
know this to be language
right and i'm not a lawyer so i'm not
going to sit there and tell you i can
read
every line and tell you exactly what it
is this is standard procedure more than
likely microsoft have these stuff in the
saturday contracts as well
but we don't have a benefit of having a
microsoft contract in front of us at
this moment right
so at this point in time you're saying
one person is squeaky clean while the
other person is dirty it's not dirty
this is business this is
this is war but i'm i go to say this
that was when game pass was in its
infancy
right if it reaches that magical number
of 30 million
that bag that you're offering capcom is
no longer viable
because the capcom is going to say i'm
sorry brother that was nice that 50
million that you gave us is cool but
i can make way more money in game pass i
can't sign this contract
right so i believe that that that type
of counter
to what's going on is not going to
benefit them in the long run
but if this is a type of uh tactic
to give them time while they get their
service
up and running so they can keep stuff
away
so they can have an actual formidable
platform to go against game pass
and then when their platform is out then
they can actually compete
i can see this working very well to give
them that distance in that time because
when you're not stronger than somebody
you have to have speed
and combinations you have to think with
your head and your feet
so they can't stand and go blow to blow
wallet for wallet with microsoft at this
point in time
right but they have to go let me get
this exclusive game for this period of
time
let me go get this for this period of
time let me lock them out from this
you have to shut doors on a competitor
as big as stronger than you
and i i i responded i got a gatekeep
microsoft i respect that
i respect the fight in them and that
this came out
i don't see what the uproar is what did
you want them to do roll over and say
put it in games
it's like look like sony what's the
point
in sony going out and you know offering
these marketing advantages offering
uh you know a for on their store when
microsoft literally can go right behind
the deal be like yeah that's cute you
want to go in game pass we'll give you
just as much
we started we're going to be the show
right i'm gonna be the show exactly and
then when you look at it the thing is
that now microsoft when you talk about
23 million subscribers right
microsoft the argument that you would
lose money not putting it on game pass
is so strong now it's only going to get
stronger
sony is going to have to pony up for
these for these types
of
[Laughter]
wrong when you do something but you
didn't intentionally do it
unintentionally
they've unintentionally made
cost of stuff more expensive for sony
because now
when sony goes to marketing stuff you
know i i don't know what goes on behind
closed doors but i'm assuming
that in order for you to keep your
service off of off a platform like game
pass you're gonna have to pay a little
extra you may have to
so they they it looks like they might
have unintentionally raised
got to do extra to make sure not only do
they get the marketing deal but it does
not go on there includes that language
to say that
let me jump in because again times are
limited and we've got a heart stop
prepared
um look at the end of the day i'm with
king like this is like
there's a war going on i told y'all barb
deep survival of the finish there's a
war going on outside no man is safe for
him you could run
you could hide you look what i'm telling
you this is what it is right now
and at the end of the day these listen
we are
privy to seeing something as gamers that
we normally
don't see right and these are the shout
out to hoglar these are
some of the structural things that are
in place with these type of deals and
contracts and don't think your favorite
provider or platform doesn't have these
similar type deals remember rise of the
tomb raider and the things that that's
true what i'm saying paris you can
relate we're destiny fans we remember
the language
with all you don't get you know xbox
doesn't get this
moon moon you know the example the
strikes the
and you know content yeah i gave addict
oh just like the crazy part
is like sony knows they're on a timer
like they they know they got to do all
this stuff because
sooner or later the halos are going to
drop the evals are going to drop
and they're like we we got to maintain
as much in our ecosystem before that
stuff comes out makes that
that already a great value even more of
a value right and at the end of the day
look it's it's business with a sense
that
you know you're giving capcom they're
giving capcom there's five million of
propose it marketing space digital real
estate you know what i mean it's an
exchange this is a beneficial they have
a huge base a huge audience and they're
gonna they're gonna get that
relationship
out of it so that's what it is the other
thing i know one last thing i want to
say about i've seen it online a lot of
people are flipping about
the parody portion right oh you know
well what about that and are they gonna
forcefully
limit the technical ability of the
series x we have to be clear
we just came off of marvel avengers
right which literally
they had the sony had the the right to
exclusive content with spider-man stuff
like that
if you look at the specifications
digital foundry did all that stuff the
series
x one was performing out performing on
the
playstation 5's marvel avengers on a
technical level so again
that right there already shows one that
they're not
in the room necessarily saying hey this
cannot be higher than this frame rate
also with resident evil specifically
they just put out the whole
spec list of resident evil on xbox
series x
resident evil uh village on what you
call playstation 5. and
it's literally was it 4k 60 with hdr on
both
um 4k uh 40 45 which is weird that's
another yeah right tracing it
whatever at the end of the day look we
don't know if the contract is
100 or it's been doctored but at the end
of the day don't
fool yourself as gamers as thinking that
these type of things
don't exist i'll let you guys finish up
before you realize i'm just wondering
can i jump in because i'm looking i know
i'm limited on time because i
i want to just say this one overall
thing about playstation and with xbox
with game pass and all that kind of
stuff
you're talking a trillion dollar company
versus a multi-billion dollar company
where the trillion dollar company
isn't relying on the gaming side of it
to to be profitable for the business
whereas you do have complete buy-in at
the executive and at the ceo level of
trillion-dollar company
and yes playstation is doing their thing
and all that but the difference on it is
this
math is undefeated it has always been
undefeated if
if microsoft can go to these third-party
publishers
and show them because you know outriders
is going to be a case study for this you
know mlb the show octopath traveler all
of that
are case studies right now if they're
literally showing
these third-party companies the data and
they're showing that
whether a person gets it on game pass or
buys it separately it has created more
engagement with your games
company and obviously microsoft is
making it financially
viable you know they're giving us some
upfront cash and probably some stuff on
the back end as well
it is going to be very hard for third
third-party companies moving forward to
want to keep their content off of that
service
if it keeps trending the way that we're
seeing but how does playstation counter
that
right they have to continue making
look let's keep it real here the last
generation we're all we're all the best
exclusive games they're on playstation
because i know that's where i was
playing them
right so they need to continue doing
that but it is going to be hard for them
to leverage the third-party deals for
everything that you guys are saying
moving forward because they're going to
look at it and go
well microsoft is offering this game
we're putting on game pads
can you match that yes the multi-billion
dollar company will be hesitant to want
to match something like that because
they're not going to be able to take as
many risks as microsoft has taken right
now that's why
they just spent 7.5 billion on bethesda
that's why you know more stuff is coming
to gamepad look
what's the name i saw on the chat lady
bond yeah you know ladies
they're just making those deals right
now you know they're going to have more
announcements
june and look i'm not saying playstation
whatever
nobody gave her this name because we
talked about it before
sarah bronkowski you know because
i would have gave her that name and you
know because she's that go-to
tight end and and she's gonna make sure
that you know she makes tom brady look
fantastic
because right now you know phil is
tom brady man yeah he used to go
phil i mean no no and i
just the last point i want to make on
this this isn't uh well
xbox is better than playstation or vice
versa it's just uh
this is just where gaming is going it is
leaning towards the subscription model
because we're seeing that it works and
kind of the point that was made before
as xbox game studios themselves starts
to ramp up and we start
to see more things come from them and
like you said it
game pass hits this magic number of
subscribers yo
it's it is what it is man i mean whether
you like it or not and again it's a
choice you ain't got to do it
yep but i know look i know my cheap ass
will be right
because it makes sense for me mob the
show absolutely added that
you waited to get your final point off
but then we'll get past yeah and it's
it's like i was saying like
i don't know about like the parody stuff
i do feel like that's probably going on
behind closed doors in some form of
fashion but not like to the degree
people think
because at the end of the day if if a
game runs significantly worse on another
platform
the only people that's really making
look bad is the developers that's not
you know that might you know hurt
microsoft a little bit because they have
to do a little refunds but
for the most part people aren't looking
at this you know microsoft dropped the
ball like when a game like outriders
doesn't work they're like who made this
game
like they're a and a company isn't going
to devalue their own brand just because
sony comes up you make their make their
version worse
like i said i'm sure that's happening to
a point you know certain things are
falling through the cracks but
as a whole that's not happening as a
whole
for the most part these developers want
it to run as best as they can on
every course exactly absolute
pleasure to have the legendary
lord paris lily in the realm not
football season paris lilly my dad
i do feel like since since you know
since paris is talking about
maybe maybe maybe the football season
stuff doesn't really happen no more
oh stop it anyway yeah you're you're
sports we gotta listen to you but look
brother an absolute pleasure to have you
around
the knowledge the information you drop
your inspiration to a lot of people in
the community
we love what you're doing and to
continue to see your ascension where can
the fine people find you what do you
have going on sir
first and foremost let me thank all of
you for having me on because it was
fantastic a lot of laughing
like i said i enjoy all your content is
great i hope
i hope i didn't get too preachy on here
um look it's all about gaming man we all
just want to have fun gaming that's what
all of this is about
preach about having fun and keeping it
positive and uh for people that want to
find me
uh you can find me at gamertag radio you
can find me over at kind of funny
um my own youtube channel which is my
name paris p-a-r-i-s
and i am on social media at fish's 696.
oh bob man an absolute pleasure sir son
of king
adam you want to give us some outros on
the way out so he left you know what
what i love about you paris you know you
know we don't see ida on everything
about gaming
nor should we nor should we can i say
that real quick yeah i
love disagreements i really do i love
not seeing eye to eye on stuff because
you learn that's how you learn that's
how you get different perspectives on
stuff i i would i would rather
get into a debate over a disagreement
respectfully
than to just everyone is unicorn and
rainbows
yeah so what i like is is you try to
take what you have you try to evolve it
like what you're doing over there with
the uh the space stuff on twitter that
that's a unique idea
you're doing it so much that people are
reaching out to be like when's iop doing
i don't even know what you're talking
about yeah follow the lady no doubt
i mean for me man i just appreciate you
came on here and
you know our goal when somebody comes on
the show is really to get to the core of
who you are
right and and try to dispel
what people may assume about a person be
because of their interactions with them
on the internet what they see
and i think you know anytime we can
achieve that we can see people in the
chat saying
hey i didn't know this about paris i
didn't realize paris was this
i love to see that so i really
appreciate you
coming on here and being honest with us
and talking about you know how
the struggle that it is to to be where
you are so we appreciate that no
no thank you again i appreciate that and
um my thing is
it's the first time i'm meeting paris
and uh
thank you sir for coming on the show i i
actually love it
but what i've learned from paris is
honesty
you know his transparency and you guys
if you if you don't
listen look and listen his hard work and
his dedication
and he told you i fell into this place i
fell into that place but it was with
this help
of these individuals that helped me this
way and i sent out
emails and facts transparency
you know a humbleness to it you know and
i truly believe that you know you're
opening up doors for other people of
color going into
different areas and thank you so much i
do appreciate it
i do appreciate your hard work because
like you said i remember when it was 15
people in the chat
but you have to have self belief within
yourself to understand that
that one person is going to hear you and
then they're gonna retweet it or they're
gonna share it with somebody else and
somebody else will hear it but
you said fun i completely let me say
there's one thing cause i meant to say
this early like as an example
y'all interview with jason ronald we
interviewed him too i watched i was like
well damn
we got to step back that's
love brother thank you thank you brother
before you leave what i like to bring
out is like you know
the stuff that you're doing in terms of
the space you know you're being very
vocal
about you know serious issues on twitter
like like five years ago
like it didn't matter what it was don't
be controversial like you know you
stay under the radar but you know
movements like this
like in three or four years it makes it
acceptable it's like okay you can still
speak about stuff you want
just just don't you know honestly i mean
yeah beautiful enjoy your sunday love
the chips
hey me too we will get you back in the
room
have a good one brother thank you
brother you guys have a good rest of
your show brother
thank you so much let's get to super
chats let's catch up okay we got a lot
of super chat
yeah we got a bunch of them let me make
sure i copy and pasted this last one
no hold on a second no doubt jdub is a
shield you know i got all of them but
just this last one
yeah it was late i mean i could do the
poll while waiting for yeah
gaming.net poll results are in the
people spoken to the question with all
the latest rumors regarding video game
company acquisitions
which pairing do you think makes the
most sense the winner of the four-way
ilp poll at 50
was microsoft and sega so that was
number one coming in at second at 21
was microsoft and nintendo in third
place at 14
of the petty lords i don't care tencent
is still out here in these streets
very close yes no no no no you want to
say
i was going to say i i'm the one that
gave the ideal for this paul i guess you
did yes you contributed to the to the
creative process
we appreciate you and last place very
close 13
surprisingly with square in saudi and
square enix
group so lord addict your thoughts on
this poll everybody
i mean 50 percent pretty close microsoft
sega with uh
microsoft nintendo second i i think
it makes better sense for for the sega
thing i i think
at the end of the day they're good on
western i don't think they have to buy
anything western i don't think that the
park
if anything western in order for them to
seriously take
game pass though they want they're going
to need the eastern help of the
atmosphere and the only way they're
going to do that is to you know
crack that piggy bank open and work
something out with segors
if they buy square enix it's it's it's a
little bit more than just cracking the
it's just if they buy square enix it's
like i said last week it
it it's a big deal but i don't think
that's happening but you know
we'll have to see exactly i do think
they're buying something i don't know
what it is think they're going to get
extra money for this girl
yeah they didn't that didn't go through
i mean they buy square enix
the thing with that discord stuff is a
lot of stuff a lot of
a lot of times you put yourself out of
reach for certain reasons yeah
you know it's not but but negotiations
is always good
i tell you this whatever they offered
them 12 billion whatever
discord goes into a public ipo
they're probably getting triple that
okay but the problem is that you give up
control you give a control
that's the thing yeah so we caught up
yeah we're caught up with all of them so
let me read that out now let's get this
going
let's read like two are we caught up i
meant to say you know what i mean
are we getting ready are we ready to
commence yes
yes yes i think i read this one but
eagles fans 76
super chat my favorite show salute to
the lords and addict
that's the new thing
this is for the comp usa and attic not
knowing what it is
oh my god i got the attic respawn
because they covered that by me what's
up i mean you guys are age-shaming like
it's it's only it's you know what's
crazy it's it's not cool for us to aid
shamelessly that's true that's
you but you're the youngest right that's
right
no no no no no no no beating up 80 year
old women
tell them tell that to the people who
made occupied travel i didn't want to do
it but
because you have a good weapon like what
am i hilarious
i got yo your camera is looking good
today it's not ghostly today
like i had a like someone kept
complaining said i look i look too blue
yeah the camera looks lit looks like
yeah so what what i did is i switched
the tint of the
of the light i have oh because like no
offense i think iced
i'm too white for a white light
it was it was making me look blue for
some reason but yeah you look
before xbox live used to play halo
online through xb connect
remember the internet keep receipts
blood
then we got gamers play with the five
dollars of a chat the hustle is real
gamers play is coming it sounds like
work but i love work
may is the month to make moves shout out
to paris and the ilp
thank you brother that hustle bro and we
got lord fonzarelli with the 5
super chat 100 people are people phil is
so down to earth
talking with him and party chat a while
back was so refreshing just to hear what
a real gamer he is
then we have john mitchell with the 10
chat paris and king in the same podcast
had to wipe my eyes
fireworks
we have a lot of the same opinions yeah
then we have let's put the crest in the
chat for the newest member of the realm
the quan
binom
then we have con artistic with the five
dollar super chat yeah
no comment no comment no comment there
we have this free r
kelly here
with the 10 super chat playstation gonna
dominate this generation sold more
consoles than xbox
you right paris all right so let's
let me explain something to you mr freya
kelly first
first your name you know you're wrong
but but i'ma say this right living off
that old metric sell all the
all the consoles that you want sell them
all
be the leader sell 100 million
all i want is game pass to equal 100
million
and when that happens you and your
console is irrelevant
we have more smoke here we got free r
kelly with the five dollars
exactly microsoft trying to hype up the
ugly girl
hey xbox game pass brother she's ugly
stop hyping her up but the pretty girl
ain't talking to you so you talk to who
talking to you
i ain't changing my name but none of
y'all no no no listen keep your name
keep it there because we want those
receipts
but you're going to change your name
when they lose this generation and you
on xbox
what's that free kells man he ain't do
it
i'm not feeling this i'm going to read
it anyway we are kelly five dollars
mass effect 2 is the goat oh oh let's
give him a gold emoji we haven't used
that
let's not do that i feel like we give
cognito too much power
no it's just the fact that he has a lot
of wrong opinions oh
are you saying that you're implying that
that cognito likes to use his power to
enforce
two the goat massive i'm done okay he
can't believe it
[Laughter]
then we have eagles fan with two dollars
super chat i'll be needs to get danny
pena aka godfrey on listen uh
the legend in the chat yes sir we on it
and we got free r kelly once again five
dollar super jack that's for me
sovereign nobody cares about the show
sony got to do so little let's be real
sustainable microsoft just throwing away
money at trash can listen
i got a i got 23 million frauds
playing baseball yo listen
i i want to say i want to say this right
the metrics is this and this is he he
said it's just he set his
own self up that game is going to sell
more on xbox
he's going to be engaged more on xbox
when sony looks at their
own platform as i think we should just
sell on xbox
because nobody's buying our first party
stuff here
raquel raquel
i like i like how you spoke for everyone
there though
yeah we have brett bigger with the ten
dollars in chat i think it's going to
backfire and sony
xbox will be like put it in game pass
and get this much more money and we
could advertise it on game pass
given how successful game pass is that
pushing sales becomes a win-win for xbox
yes this is true then we have free r
kelly once again
five dollars if it's at king you lost
brother sony gotta do a little to get us
to buy ps5s nobody playing game pass
when god of war five comes out
and when you finish gotta yeah there you
go two days
when you blaze through your little
eight-hour experience eight hours
how's that mouse morale is working out
for you right now
on it on his 15th playthrough right here
hashtag
see you in june there we go
he's put a correction out it's 22
minutes actually just did put a
correction out and said it
was 22. 22 officially paid for lock
stock barrel
the other four i mean other three i mean
even
even if it's 22 that's still over four
million in three months
how much is that playstation now though
like the last time they did numbers it
was like two so yeah it was microsoft
grew
what they reported the last in three
months yeah they still two million
all right make sure um make sure you
guys are just looking at whatever's
after the wise old gamer focus that way
you just put me there
um there we have it lord roughness with
the five pound super chat at the start
of the year if there was one game you
can say is not going in game pass it
would have been resident evil no it
would have been emma be the show
actually so i think this contract is
fake
yeah we can exactly clutch man with the
five dollars of chat can't watch live
working today but i'll jump in at five
o'clock when you finish this fire intro
are you implying that we we have a long
time sir
all love and shout out to having paris
on it thank you
then we have jade dumb as a shill with
the ten dollar super chat hope you're
enjoying that playstation sir
he's been he's been playing playstation
yeah he won that playstation
king is christopher hart listening to
paris's facts
math is undefeated yeah i like that for
paris and that's
that's the guy who won the playstation 5
trillion dollar company last i checked
100 billion is significantly less than a
trillion
game passes the future will they ever
learn king no they won't sir
they will not learn we will force them
to bend the knee
then we have the wise old gamer five
dollars if we chat morning lords i just
want to remind you that there are two
types of gamers
those who believe mass effect 1 is the
best mass effect than those who are
simply wrong
disable his axes
remove him easily
two dollar super chat microsoft to
tencent get out of here
then we got free r kelly once again
microsoft is not about to be pimping out
the eastern market
capcom konami square bandai are all
loyal to sony
uh say hello to outriders and he said
could you not rush
wow listen listen loyalty yo why is it
that when they
when it's not certain that they're on
the floor they don't want to say yeah
you know you got on your platform
if it turns out that all of these are
wrong and kojima's making
them like someone screenshot this chat
man screenshot this chat
loyalty is subjective to cash brother so
yeah
thank you for always mentioning the
fight thank you for saying that because
we all used to get yeah
yeah we got a lot of fun i get a lot of
hate but i'm gonna keep going yeah we
haven't been
doing it as thoroughly as we knew we got
gerald mack five dollars to be attacked
once that game passed his 40 million you
are going to need to sell as many piss
station watches
it's 30 million is the magic number and
subscription services
uh and you know you you learn that from
hbo max and other
you know subscription services 30
million is the the number and microsoft
is almost there okay
then we got goblin time two pounds
through the chats
i like that bubsy 3d remastered e3
first of all i like bubsy cut it out
they already did bubs e3 they made it
again
no it was like a pc like spyro no not
like that it was a point
but they brought bubsy back for sure i
know that
but when it's in game pass i'll figure
it out
then we got geek head 188 with the five
dollar super chat
i don't care we still smoking that ps5
pack oh my god
calm yourself
[Laughter]
first of all that's so chicago that's so
shut down yes it is
that was wow okay and we have the wise
old gamer once again five dollars super
chat
mlb realizing this week that a gang bang
is better than staying free for today
then we got one bad mother shout out to
my bad mother 10 super chat
congratulations on a great x-cast
appearance by the mayor of these gaming
streets lord cognito
appreciation to the iop for consistently
bringing cats and dogs together
and encouraging positivity thank you
brother
love your content love what you're doing
that meant a lot you know what the
mission is it's always going to be
gaming bro bring everybody together
regardless
what side of defense you will continue
100 oh we are caught up
all right let's get this let's go it's
soft
you're up some new uh ip exclusive
what's going on yeah so uh on thursday i
believe
playstation and firewalk studios
announced a publishing partnership for a
new multiplayer ip
and some of the names that are
associated with
firewalk's aaa team are some big names
in the multiplayer space
and what i want to ask you guys is
this is the first time in a while that
we've seen sony
even talk about bringing something
multiplayer centric from there kind of
first party publishing whatever but it's
it's a sony thing
onto their platform and when you look at
the people
on this team it seems kind of obvious to
me that this is not a small game this is
not some
one-and-done multiplayer thing they want
this to be a huge game
possibly a game as a service and
i want to ask you guys if you think this
is the right thing for playstation to do
or will the playstation faithful
feel hey this is further
uh evidence that you guys are destroying
what playstation is all about
trying to trying to be about this
multiplayer stuff and moreover trying to
be
a game as a service if this is what it
is because it feels like this is what it
is
um and there are a couple of things just
to add to that real quick
i mentioned in the mlb the show
and what was funny about mlb the show to
me there are certain modes in that game
wrote to the show
um stuff like that that for whatever
reason
in this year's game have been
intrinsically tied to diamond dynasty
which is their sort of microtransaction
sort of card game thing right and it was
very strange to me that this is the
first time that
those two modes have been so
intrinsically tied to one another
when the game is going to multiply right
and specifically it's going to game pass
playstation made it seem like they
didn't really know that this game was
coming the game passed until
it got announced and when you look at
the changes made to mlb the show
in that regard it doesn't quite fit
because it's like because it's not a
change it's not a quality of life change
to the game it doesn't make the game
better doesn't change it
it's just a different way to progress
and roll to the show
it honestly they didn't have to do so it
feels like they
they were thinking like hey this thing
is going in the game pass let's try to
get as much money out of this as
possible
so in general what do you guys think of
this
kind of direction where playstation is
is showing that they want to be more in
the multiplayer space there was another
thing for playstation australia sony
australia uh that kind of hinted at
socom as well coming back so that's
so what do you guys think about this is
this is this the right move should they
stay in their lane
because they've been out of this lane
for a long time let's get attic i'm
curious because um
you know how you feel about this this
potential new multiplayer ip
in this approach i feel like people are
tr
are fooling themselves when you see
people on twitter that's saying oh
you know they they they can't do this
they can't do that
and then they and then they like they
pretty much put like
microsoft online microsoft they put
playstations games on like in their
studios on such a huge high pedestal
and i'm just like if they're so talented
they could easily do both like
and it's just like look like people are
like oh they
they they can only you know focus on
single player no they can focus on
multiplayer too
it's just they weren't right now they're
trying to
to be a more diverse library because
let's just be real here
last generation they could do that
because microsoft wasn't doing anything
right but now they're they're looking
over there like sony
the sony's just looking over there in
the microsoft land in the
world
and they're just like we got to compete
better
like let's just be real that's the
reason that they lower playstation now
that's the reason they give discounts on
buying playstation now a whole year
that's the reason they've done the
majority
so that's the reason you're seeing games
go day and day in playstation plus
it's always that's always say like it
doesn't matter what side you're on with
console you have
you want these companies to battle it
out because it's only good on us
and it's in the multiplayer scene let's
be real here
you guys could say god of war is amazing
an amazing game sold very well
horizon amazing game so very well what
are the not what are the top things
being played in the industry right now
all multiplayer
by far all multiplayer the fortnites you
look over on pc
dota
so question addict do you feel so this
is in your mind is this going to be a
ps5 pc game
or will they even try to incorporate ps4
they've already they've they they've
already
addressed that they said we're going to
be making more multiplayers like a year
and a half ago and they're going to be
on pc2 they've already addressed that
and the way they were talking about
these these these
these multiplayer games it seems like
they're going to be day and date
the multiplayer games so you know they
need that because at the end of the day
you can't improve your brand if you're
only making one type of game
and i understand they make those games
phenomenal
but not everybody plays those type of
games that's a good point
and if you can't if you can't be more
diverse because
let's be real back in the day back when
dragon quest was only coming on on
playstation back when yakuza was only
coming out on playstation
they were a very diverse library but now
it's not like that
yeah they got to be more diverse or
people can look at game pads and be like
yo i get xbox to play everything i want
multiplayer single player
everything i want sure i'm missing out
on the god of wars and horizons which i
would recommend you still get a
playstation for those
but at the end of the day is a couple
games a generation
worth me losing on the diversity that
you can get with game pass
i feel that so they they're looking at
that kind of scenario they're like look
we got to be more diverse we got to
bring more games to pc
we got to build up our audience and we
got to make multiplayer games that
people want
like they're justifying charging for
playstation plus when
they have no multiplayer games that's a
good point let's get king and i'm
curious about king like
what do you feel about this direction
multiplayer exclusive ip
playstation a lot of these names you
know they're attaching to this
you know that's for shock value shout
out to cliff
belinsky um cliffy
remember when cliffy b came out with
that multiplayer game
boom hit the floor all right it was
mulch it was it was it was
it was much hype you know hubris before
the show they gotta go
they team look beautiful god bless but
i'm i'm saying this to say this part
right
all right multiplayer game interaction
with everyone across the boards
um they look over at microsoft because
microsoft uh
now you know xbox live uh to play free
to play games it's it's free now
yeah you know you guys are jumping in
for free because though that
money being made on free to play games
is an incredible value on your platform
you know sony was eating on that part
right there while microsoft played
ignorance and that was that
that was uh a a bad move on microsoft
part now they rectified that right
so i don't know if this game is going to
be free to play i don't know
what's going to be the business model
behind this game right what we do know
is going to be tied to a playstation
platform
yes do they need multiplayer games yes
they do do they need to diversify their
portfolio yo
hell yeah they must in order to
uh to grow you have to change adapt to
get better
i'm looking at it saying they're
complicit
i've been saying that jim dance moves
ryan is going to take
uh sony into a different way a different
space you may not like it you guys may
want your one-and-dones you may want
your three-hour four-hour games
that you can get to go platinum now i'm
a platinum this game is four hours
and i'm a platinum you know i'm a
platinum this uh
it's four hours you know i'm gonna find
the book back under the bus
you can't be using that voice to act
like every game you know they gotta get
the rick wars
i gotta platinum this baby like king how
did we go from
eight hours a minute ago until now four
listen to morales is three hours without
the cutscenes
oh my god let's keep it for a great
three hours yeah
but fantastic though it's not worth 70.
fall back
um it's not 70. well it's not for me
anyway like i was saying they need this
multiplayer stuff to get that recurring
dollar
however it works for them do i hope they
be successful yes because
that allows like uh addict was saying
more competition right now can they
compete in this area where microsoft has
been living in this space because
everybody knows
when you want to play multiplayer games
oh i'm gonna go to microsoft
when you want to play those
single-player experiences you go over to
sony right
microsoft is looking over at sony and
said we need some of that single player
stuff over here
they're working on that and sony is
looking at microsoft saying we need this
multiplayer stuff
over here so as a company
as a as as as a group they're working
on fixing their weaknesses and you can't
say
that's a bad thing that's a great thing
that they're doing absolutely
absolutely yeah i'll jump in i think uh
solve an attic you guys make king as
well make great points
look um i love it for me because again i
know the xbox community gets mad with me
but this is my hashtag just one
for playstation you know what i'm saying
because my whole thing was don't get me
wrong we love
the single-player third-party cinematic
experience that i always check you're
wrong about that
oh god that we want xbox to have at
least
one new ip in that genre in the same
token i'm gonna keep that same
energy and i want playstation to have a
new ip that is multiplayer focused for
like king said for diversity
and i'm gonna be real like they got that
team over there i think is tony i've got
his last i can't pronounce hsu i always
put you in his last name
but yo he was like one of the leads on
um destiny with activision
they got my boy john wisniewski over
there he's a pvp crucible
lord ryan ellis like that the team over
there i think herman house is on there
they got former destiny
halo apex legend and call of duty devs
on deck
so the talent for probably monsters is
gonna i've been hearing about probably
bosses for a minute
i mean so i think firewalk solved
correct before they're under they're
like the studio subsidiary underneath
that the bigger brand of
exactly monsters so look you know if
blockbuster's only
mantra is the new wave like king said
like
you gotta have one in your own you know
like soft said you know with the
multiplayer
microtransaction component that
consistent engagement have
you been begging for socom
and um we that was that
that that's a drop the mic right yeah
you know that's a drop down
socom that's a drop the microphone all
of us
love us you want me to interact with
that playstation 5 on a week on a daily
basis
put that so calm in there it's fire
shout out the bar he legally he said
where's his daddy come from ice
bar you know i love you brother but it's
like if you look at the majority
of the dominant successful um ips from
sodium
that's the homie come on
look at the end of the day like i said
you know it's good to see
a new ip multiplayer as the focus i
don't think it's going to be a new ip
at first when i when i first read it i
thought it was so calm
but that's separate it's something else
yeah
yeah so at the end i personally feel
like
it doesn't matter what it is as long as
it's good like that
that's absolutely cool that's why i like
me incognito we described like the just
one thing because
to me they don't need to make a new ip
they just need to make a game that's
good
like you talk about microsoft right you
talk about microsoft no no i'm talking
about sony too i'm just saying like
if it was socom it wouldn't matter if
it's new ip odip reimagined ip if it's
good people are gonna flock to it no
of course for sony i get your point on
that part for microsoft the caveat is
different because i want a new
protagonist
leading into this new generation a new
face yeah we just need a new face that's
what i'm just trying to see in
the scene so that's all i mean we're
gonna have plenty i wanna i wanna
address in the chat real quick
all right hey halo death seeker i know
you got timed out i don't know if you're
back in here
being a little bit rude a little bit
disrespectful
but just you know the language sir but
beyond that like you're talking about
playstation 3 stuff like
they literally went an entire generation
without giving you a true multiplayer
game
they crossed over they crossed over
factions from
from the remaster of matt of the last of
us
and you had uncharted 4 multiplayer
that's pretty that's pretty much
it yeah and your head has been relying
on third party that's what i'm trying to
say
was their killzone multiplayer launch
then they just closed down one of the
multiplayers for one of those uh
those are that those ip uncharted
something like that was uncharted they
closed
they turned one of the studios that made
multiplayers into making horizons
so like yeah they're actually like like
backing away from obviously now they're
backing towards you we can all agree
that that isn't necessarily the strength
of the playstation brand
but they need it and they're going for
bangers you know jim martin jim ryan
hey y'all asking for bangers
at the end of the day i'm happy to hear
this announcement but that's all i got
super chat will move forward for the
final topic uh i think we have rocker
corey with the two dollars if we chat
playstation equals
hashtag for the payers
for the prayers soon wow wow
let it rain then we got midway monster
five dollars
just woke up glad to catch you guys
doing your thing hit the like button
have a great day
sony needs to work on that
infrastructure
yeah for real or they're gonna be
they're gonna be using this i mean
this is the thing you worry about
security with those dudes
like you playing these multiplayer games
and then you realize
you've been hacked like oh
yeah i missed some stuff real quick
oh lord they coming for me continue okay
we have nando nando supes with the two
dollar super chat a link to the past
best zelda don't play me
then we got gerald mack five dollar
super chat lords i apologize for the
vulgarity just
tired of these dudes capping for the
playstation nation
fear is becoming a meme yeah they don't
worry about it they're terrified
mm-hmm no doubt then we have goblin time
with the five pound super chat
thoughts on possible forza horizon
location rumors pointing towards mexico
i mean yeah there are a lot of different
biomes in mexico
i do i really like one in japan
i would love one but i keep hearing that
it's not there
yeah i keep hearing it it will at some
point that would go there eventually
he spit he's like killzone had more time
gran turismo drive club predator
bloodborne
multiplayer that predated the dreams
okay i'm talking about more traditional
shootie shooting
i will give you i will give you kills on
an uncharted and grand trip
but that was like how long like you
can't you can't work
hold up hold up you can't tell xbox
people because i've seen you say
when people bring sunset overdrive but
how long ago was that
and then when you come in here for i'm
not giving you predator
give it of that we both know those are
add-ons and we ain't gonna
act like predator we ain't gonna act
like anyone has ever been in a party
or let's get that kill going on when's
the last time using a party and someone
said yo let's play something
anyone said predator nobody
brought up examples you know what was
the examples though he brought up
ancient old stuff that charted nowhere
there was just wood games those was wood
games
they went plastic what else did we have
we have the wise old gamer ten dollars
super chat [ __ ] yo
i'm banging my white tee all in the
clothes it gave me my wife
i blinked with my wife you said friends
in my white tee screw her throw back i
look clean in my white teeth
i know what you're doing i know what
you're doing we come in tv
then we have dan lazaro with the two
dollar super chat ps video pass they
don't have any good movies
then we have jean-marc louis four dollar
super chat they're going to read the box
they're going to redbox the game anyway
wow let me see what else
is right they did have fall guys last
year that i will give them fall
yeah they did focus on a little bit that
was a really good look on their end
because no doubt because
clearly they came in they swooped that
stuff up
i missed one from brett bring them hold
on bro bring them ten dollars we chat
software costs are less than hardware
costs sony has got to have
has got to have some of the fraudulent
sales like those bots buying on
playstation 5 now to survive
xbox beats sony the gaming as a service
case closed to sony loses
monster rocker corey probably i don't
see him yeah tony bryant
tony what did you say let's say what you
say tony we're going to repeat it
because we got it we got to show love
see what you said bro cause we i'll i'll
find her you guys just continue i don't
think it's here
we almost got 700 in this channel
watching let's hit
just continue the podcast all right cool
so we're gonna move this joint
forward oh we got one more hold on oh
sorry eagles fan 76 five dollar super
chat socom is good but the kiddos don't
know what that
what what that is going to be hard to
pull them away from fortnite cod
rainbow six no looking for that we're
not looking for those kids
we're not looking like when you say
socom we're not looking
you know it's crazy i went upstairs and
saw my son playing um pub g
first of all he got a chicken dinner
right there while i was watching him
salute to the he is the mastermind
anyway but
he tends to play fortnite i want so calm
for me
i want the old heads what's up with
these old heads yeah with the so-called
i want that for me i want to go back in
the hallway
and shoot down i want that for me so
yeah i'm not looking for the fortnite
crowd to jump on my wave no i want
and i don't want it made like fortnight
no i want it made like
so-called like classic so-called i sent
it to i sent it to you on the discord
thing
oh just me who think just read it just
read it and then we'll get the new ones
and move on
yeah just okay let me bring it back up
just uh
five dollar super chat from uh tony
bryant that's who we're talking about
right
yes great show love the insight from
paris one man campaign continues
tomorrow austin creed
will happen into existence sarah bond
sony trees multiplayer how it treats it
stands don't know
so we're good yeah we good i think we're
good all right cool
king this is you playstation
uh video pass right let me frame it up a
little bit
um yes so it looks like they put out
well
apparently it was leaked on a sony uh
kingston sony official website polish
sony uh official website but now looks
like it's confirmed shout out to hector
ramirez my man
manchester lawyersgamer.net articles up
right now so playstation plus video pass
is real
and testing in poland so they had the uh
the look out there so it looks like they
had like a
venom zombieland double tap
diesel bloodshot and stuff like that
yeah
the goat movie so yeah so again
king wanted to talk about it as this
potential maybe
uh addition to playstation plus
lord king you mean uh
you mean king wants to preach yeah it's
kingland i just want to say hey
tv tv tv be back baby
we got a console for you johnny m is
under control of the building
dance moves ryan for doing everything he
did in 2013
he back baby
are you implying that the focus is not
game sir oh the focus is triple a games
so y'all gonna get the same games we got
again we're just gonna re-skin them
so get your 70 dollars ready
but we really won't focus on movies here
so we're going to take our content they
went and did a deal with netflix they
went and did the deal with disney
they're selling their this is how they
can make money so they realize
see this is where uh the money man comes
in
you can look at existing stuff over
there that's making money
and stuff that wasn't making money and
potential stuff that could make money
that's why they was closing down those
stores until y'all started screaming
don't close down the stores
but never brought a video game you guys
are yelling oh don't close down the
playstation 3 store but never go in
there to buy a playstation 3 game
don't take this away from me but never
use it
if he was using it he wouldn't have to
say i'm gonna shut this down
now these ips that they have over here
for these movies and stuff
they're able to make money from these
deals right so i knew that a a
streaming service or something like that
was gonna happen when they were starting
to close down
other avenues and it was going to focus
on it it makes total sense that
you have these wonderful movies inside
your catalog
and you're the owners of the said
catalog why don't you
have action it's on your service you
know
i'm impressed with you look at you no
it's just the fact that
if it's like if you break dance right
it's you break dance you you why are you
pop locked
stop pop-locking do what you do do what
you do do what you do best
okay are you not gonna beat anybody at
something that they do microsoft
was started to do a studio like you
remember that
we gonna make a studio
what was that whack game that they did
the movie with the
tv device yes listen
what i got to say is this this is only
something positive
if they're going to add it into
playstation now to give value to
playstation now
why not pre right why not have your
playstation now show you something
different
what a game pass doesn't have do
something different don't try to do the
same exact thing i don't want a game
pass on playstation per se
yes i love that there but i would like
to go over to playstation now
to get what they have uniquely over
there and
the fact that they have these ips these
movies and stuff like that on their
platform yes i would buy into the
ecosystem before that and i think it's a
positive thing
them talking about tv movie movie or
whatever but
i just see how a lot of things mirror
stuff and it's funny but
i want to hear the narrative and what
your take is on this stuff
no doubt no doubt attic where you at man
playstation video pass
it is what it is i don't particularly
care about it like i don't think this is
really relevant in terms of gaming
but it's like it does give it value i
mean we can't pay that
when people go get amazon prime yeah
there's some people that get prime
amazon prime because they got the you
know the the prime
feature on on on amazon where they can
get their mail
early there's some people that got
primed that got the other one because
they wanted to watch tv
so i mean we can't like valuing
one and bringing value to the video one
can bring more value to the other one
so preach no i i feel you uh i hear what
you're putting down brother
lord solving get a chance to get your
thoughts on this sir
i mean i agree with king a hundred
percent i agree
it's just adding value they don't have
or are unwilling
to make that make that move just yet to
be putting their their first party games
in their first
day and date so they have something that
compares at least in that regard
to game pass so they have other things
that can add value to either ps plus or
ps now whichever which way they try to
do it moving forward
um just you know shove as much as you
can into that pause
and just you know give people as much
value as you possibly can
while skirting the game issue yeah um
until you feel comfortable doing it or
like i
keep saying i think you know all of
these sort of indies and stuff that are
coming to the platform that would be
well served to
put those games in either ps now or ps
plus give those games to people up front
decide to get people used to the fact
that they're getting
brand new stuff in these uh services and
that's it but yeah
pat it with as much as you can and why
not if you own these
these studios and you own these these
movie rights just throw it in there
i watch them you know i'll watch venom
again and not not to mention
that you could potentially grow the
gaming portion side when people are
getting the prime for for the sony thing
and they're like oh i get this too and
then they you before you know it they're
downloading games on it and they're like
oh now it's actually pretty good then
they're playing more games they're
buying more games
it's funny because it's just like like
king said like you know
tv tv tv it just feels like it's so
weird that we're talking about this
because it's like
they're adding value by putting all this
other stuff that
ex you know xbox got shot down for
and you know it's funny but at the end
of the day like when you see
again everything turns into a game pass
conversation but when you see
that juggernut you have to figure out a
way
to talk about it think about it this way
right you're watching a movie on
uh sony's uh whatever right the sony
streaming
video app and that's inside however they
turn to use it
right and it pops up a game
if you like this maybe you might like
this game
and you click it because they have these
little tabs and stuff and then you click
it
and it takes you to that game and you
have a demo for that game or whatever
and then you're like oh man i do like
this
so you can marry the whole movie
video game thing through that structure
if they do it right
if it's done correctly to marry movie
and video game that entertainment value
is there and being that they own this
stuff
let's see it's it's different if
microsoft goes out like they did made a
studio and fall flat on their face
why are you making movies like why why
are you making don't don't do that
why are you running um
they could be obviously we've seen that
sony wants to get a little bit more into
the movie space
so maybe they're trying to you know to
get more casuals to try their games out
it's like look like
watch the god of war movie at the end
they're linked together and it's like
you got a god of war game you want to
play that like
exactly exactly and we see we see let me
jump in because we see
obviously the push last of us is is
going to get that
that movie they got my man what is it
pedro pascal right silva you know i mean
i'll be up in there um look we had a
great discussion with this on shout out
to fame level one gaming we had a great
discussion with this with um them
rand jeff grub you know what i'm saying
in the crew and look
it ain't moving a needle for me per se
but at the end of the day like so i've
said like king said
it's additional value to a service right
it's something additive so at the end of
the day to me
is it i don't look at it like oh this is
this one to one answer the game pass
type situation
i think they're just trying to position
themselves where they're building
more value to that service and let's be
real i mean
you know the parts the picture division
the movie division the tv division all
that stuff
you know maybe they could leverage some
of that content like i remember at one
point king help me out here um
didn't they have like a hero style tv
show
yeah powers hours yes
right so what's funny is i i was i
downloaded power because i wanted to
watch
power oh my god
i'm just like i'm just like yo like this
doesn't look like the drunk scene i was
watching
and i think that you know with um
and i don't know if jim dance moves ryan
i joke around i don't know if jim damn
smooth ryan
is involved in this level of the video
stuff
right but he has to be keen on it and
know about it
right so uh the fact of the matter is if
they can leverage this stuff is great oh
i just want to address one thing let's
go
and i noticed this happens a lot and i
hear people narratives talking about
sony didn't know about the game going
inside game pass and sony didn't know
if they truly feel like that i don't
know what to tell them listen
let me let me let me tell you something
you walk in your house you see some
man's shoes at your ch
at your bed we talking about the mlv
show
yeah the mlb the show all right that's
the dev kit
that man shoots at your back all right
so
you've seen the dev kit don't act like
you don't know what's going on in your
house
are you it relying that saudi is
complicit i'm i'm comply
i'm implying that they complicit they
know what's going on when they're not
there
all right so the fact that it came out
and this is our game pass they got a
heads up
right because don't tell me no one knew
they got slipping exactly so when it
came out they was like oh we had no idea
you saw the shoes
next to the bed okay so don't don't
don't play with me
talking about y'all don't know if y'all
want to run with that you sony dudes
don't want to run with that run with it
hang out with it
but give this is the visualization if
you see boots in your house
next to the bed those size 12s inside
13.
next to the bed and you wear size eight
nine members
nah nah king you got you gotta mess up
man if it's me though they they size 16
so there you go
so you got them you walk in your house
you see a size 16
oh good god somebody getting knocked
down somebody getting knocked down
something's happening and you better get
to the bottom of this
or just turn around and walk out and
obviously obviously these are jokes
we don't have our shoes behind mary
woman's bags
hold up just had to address that thank
you for clarifying
that situation oh shout out to the quads
he bought a classic t
no doubt i see that what i'm saying but
yeah like i would say i just would be
curious
a merchandise giveaway yeah like like a
ticket
they buy one they got a ticket oh the
quads got the sticker too i see you guys
nice you know what i'm saying you know
what i'm saying so um yeah so like i
said to king's point you know
yo pong stop it i see you in there pong
you contributing to kings nonsense
oh what i would say is as far as i want
to see
if they do leverage that movie that tv
studio see if they do
it like a netflix exclusive you know i
could imagine they had like a dope
series you know what i'm saying yeah
that's exclusive and you can get it on
playstation that would be kind of funny
they should i i don't think this has
anything to do with the gaming scene no
no
yeah they they just want to give the the
service more value in general
right so like it's like i said you know
someone
let's say they start making uh making
shows it's on like the equivalent of of
wand division or
or falcon like they're like oh okay let
me get this and then it's like i said
and that's gonna leak over but today you
get that crossover so i didn't even
manage to move it yeah i look at it as a
one-on-one thing the gamepad no but just
out of the service
we just it's funny i i just i just
finished having a nice conversation with
lady april from lords of gaming
and we talked about uh at the amazon
lord of the rings mmo uh being cancelled
and we talked about the same thing where
it's like they would have liked to have
had that you know they have that
lord of the rings prequel show coming on
and they would have at least like to
have that sort of
that transmog thing where you're talking
about both things at the same time
um and obviously that's not gonna happen
now because the game is gone right but
i mean it's that thing where when you
have those properties under your belt
yeah i mean you have you have to take
advantage of that right and playstation
is their
dominant division right now exactly the
movies are not at least i don't know i
mean recently
i would assume that it wasn't as
dominant as it used to be so why not
leverage your best
property into movies and get that stuff
going look that's what i got solved
let's get
the uh should i go to pull into super
chat so what you want to do first i got
the super chats i got
okay it's so funny yeah we got
we got stitch with the five dollar super
chat why is addict's cap on backwards
and mario is happy about those
look man i woke up at 11 30.
okay and oh no the reason it's backwards
is because like i like my ears being
covered by it but if you do it the way
it's supposed to
like but they'll have to look i like the
whole logo show and if you do it the way
like
like continue i'll show you what it
looks like if i have it on right
why y'all acting like gta 5 and warzone
ain't holding the king of game
sony down um as to my knowledge those
games are elsewhere as well
if halo comes out and hits the way it's
supposed
to hit and you know that's going to be
everywhere
playstation needs a counter to that well
i feel that i feel like
what else we got then we got philly
eagle five dollar super chat psa twitter
is not a gaming platform all you numbers
do is just stop you only contribute to
one
two maybe three uh top sales of the
games
that's true buying more games bonzarelli
gaming with the father
just want to thank you guys for helping
push me to going live on cam you guys
showed me the way
yeah okay you can't abandon people if
you don't come on cam i'm just it's not
me
that's that's that's that's my guy you
know we talk offline and stuff like that
and hell yeah support him yeah
yeah his new show yeah games talk live
starts today
chris brown support my man fonzarelli
salute no doubt now we have mass erect
with the two dollar super chat yo king
you getting video pass
if you're coming playstation now on this
date and date shout out to me
there we go tony bryant five dollars 22
million game pass plus 20 million xbox
live gold subs a lot of money to put
towards growth
yeah sometimes people forget these
numbers are monthly
there are millions upon millions of
dollars coming in monthly
yes they don't know about that
2 million and 22 million is a different
number bro
then we got digging smacks
been a playstation fan but microsoft uh
walking up to these studios like robert
redford from indecent proposal
made me buy a series x and game pass
yeah yeah she gone for the night
what you doing for the night woody
harrelson looking sick
oh there we go we got skate lights with
the five dollars with jack
so many canceling game studios and
opening tv studios
he said yo shut down japan
and open up japan and the movies though
baby
here we have adriana gomes with the 2
super chat video pass
i use cody on my series x amen to that i
will neither confirm or deny that cody
is on my series
iop does not uh prove the methods of
your video do what you got to do
god bless you hey i know one thing man
homeboy over there he has no issue stuff
being day and day oh yeah
every day yeah
on everything
with the five pounds of attack now sony
folk can watch movies in those banger
sequel four-year gaps
wow i know how the movie gonna be longer
in the game
gonna be turning out exclusives from
these 23 studios on a quarterly basis
but isn't it like they make games that
play like movies so now they're gonna
make movies that play like games
i can't with you then we have louisville
with the five dollar super chat
i hope sony realizes that sooner or
later xbox will release an absolute
banger with just 30 dev houses
yeah it's coming it's coming um
done we have free r kelly
okay yep and then free we if we are
kelly five dollars
man halo 4 was trash and guardians was
worse it's over for halo and he laughing
he's like it's like seven years
ago like a decade ago
there's more people playing halo right
now than people playing god of war
oh my god yeah because it's done anyway
but don't worry when it's all game pass
you'll play it again too anyway
let's get this phone get up out of here
weekly poll if the rumored sony and
capcom
contract with specific provisions to
keep resident evil village off
game pass for a year turns out to be
true
do you feel this is an unfair business
practice
in the games industry the choices are a
yes
performance parity and game service
exclusivity should never
be involved b no these deals happen
all the time for all platforms it's a
mutual beneficial relationship
or c i don't care unless it's my
favorite game to complain
complain about with restrictions shout
out to all those in the chat let's get
wise old gamer real quick
oh wow hold on a second let me go let's
look at that
oh wow the wise old gamer mlb to sony
i still love you everyone else has to
use a condom wow
that's the boots
anyway those are the choices we rocked
about when it goes up again
salute to lord paris who came through
pulled up
dropped some tremendous knowledge and
someone just copped some gear
uh oh razzie with the purple oh that
classic t-shirt
i salute to you my guy salute to you you
know what we should do
we should do a because we we we've done
a members giveaway we've done
a patreon giveaway you should do like if
you buy gear
from uh from from the store like you get
like a like a little thing
like a raffle and give away something
for that too yeah we can figure it out
all good give it back to the realm
that's what i got
again shout out to paris but he was
tremendous a lot of gems
dropped lord solve where can the fine
people find you what you got
what about skipping at it lord that
we're going to five people how to get no
love
you can follow me on uh on twitter at
lord addict iop
you can find me at the picket line this
chat this week
uh you can also find me uh i'll be
streaming
souls uh monday at 1 p.m and i'll be
having an attic show at
tuesday at 5 p.m uh so definitely catch
it in that
yes i will be streaming maternal oh all
right well hopefully man you can get
this game down
i know uh you want to do that monday
instead of demonstrating i think i have
a whatchamacallit on monday i think i
have a podcast after that so i'm
checking my
my twitter because you know people fail
to realize they they hit me up the day
of
yo remember we talked about last week
i'm like uh no no
no i don't because i have like 500
messages every day
so no i do not remember definitely keep
that in mind i'm going to be re
streaming return on on this channel that
you're watching now so definitely sub if
you want to see that
i'm going to show i'm going to show
these uh these people how to play that
oh probably probably gonna get destroyed
but we're gonna go with
we're gonna go with i'm not getting
destroyed man people doubted me in
bloodborne
that's a beat game people doubted me a
cuphead that's a beat game people
doubted me at any other game i can think
of and those games are beat too
if you're gonna doubt me uh ever turn
almost forgot the name of it
you're gonna have to you're gonna have
to get that word out i like the fact
that eternal's a difficult game because
this is gonna be addicting his back oh i
should have been his back
um don't worry everybody else going to
forget the name of that game too
nobody paying seventy dollars for yeah i
wanna i wanna i wanna thank paris for
come on he's a he was a wonderful guest
uh we we still have more guests for you
guys we are not done
with the world and i'll announce right
now we are bringing the
the e3 prediction shows back yes we
still are
in terms of put in the comment section
who you guys would like to see on the
xbox and nintendo
obviously sony don't have one right now
because we don't know nothing about what
sony's doing
but right now we will have an xbox one
and we will have a nintendo one put
in the comment section we'll do
something that we can do something we
just gotta figure out so we gotta
we can't we can do it we
yeah but the the part about it though
king is like we don't know when they're
doing it
and the funny thing is we're so booked
that we're gonna have to do the sony
thing like in the middle of the week
like okay
[Laughter]
and we will be live reacting to all the
e3 press conferences
so look for blaze uh lord blaze
and king on the xbox one because that's
a that's that's
that's a thing now because he's a he's
an xbox guy
in the building lord josh would like to
be on the lord frost from lord on the e3
prediction episode say which one though
which one we can own a bunch of them so
let us know lord frost which i can't
trading
all right so we got that lord waking up
on people find you what you got going on
sir
yeah first off big shout out to paris
yes he
do came on and and spoke facts um
he was just being super honest and i
appreciate that i i really really
really appreciate him coming on here and
talking about the things that he talked
about
because you know again it's all about
the games it's all about us being united
not not bringing each other down and
breaking each other down so
that was fantastic absolutely um you can
find me
actually i'm off today so i'm gonna play
some mlb to show maybe i don't know i
don't know if cog wants to get on a
little bit you know what i love about
mlb the show
what i love about mlb the show is they
you have you can pick your different
hitting styles
your different pitching styles my
pitching style is a little it's old
school the old one
you know i love how this gay boy gave
passing you just know everything about
it now
i got stuff to do yeah i heard that
though but i wasn't buying it before
remember when we was at pax and this is
i had jamie do his first interview uh
all paul kabatsu doing his first
interview
and you know uh mlb the show was there
and
didn't know that it was going to xbox
didn't know that it was going to game
pass but
i i i'ma keep the same energy i always
said that that was the best baseball
game and
all baseball games came out and tried to
compete with it but couldn't
so the fact that i get a chance to play
it and like and they have different
pitching styles
this is great i just don't like your
enthusiasm but it fits for me though
yo they
where can five people find you what you
got going on sir i'm elmo b the show
on the game oh or or playing outriders
in gamepad oh or doing whatever the hell
i like
in game where y'all gonna be at
it's probably a game pass and if you're
not in game pass you're probably on
playstation wiping the dust off your
console
oh but listen don't play it too much
because they got a limited time only
that's that's c-bomb
it is a time limit on your game
experiences but
i do say this follow me on twitter king
david otw i want to give a shout out to
paris because paris came
with great energy yes like he when he
came in the room
see i come in every every show with
different music different energy
so when paris usually i get the after
the guesses there
but paris came in when i was uh coming
in and
and he was like whoa what's going on
it's it was great to have him on
and i like to speak to all the gamers
right because you know we have a lot of
younger gamers
but to to connect with i feel like it's
the other way around we have more older
gamers on then
that's fine that's cool anyway um but i
like speaking to older gamers and
hearing their experiences because he
told you he took the bus here
yeah yeah like i i did like the uh
his games and how he was a nintendo dude
but nintendo uh you know xbox gave him
all that access
yeah and it's beautiful to see and the
honesty
so um i really loved him on today and
it's going to make me
look deeper into what's going on because
this is my first interaction with him
yes so this is going to make me look
deep into his content no doubt no doubt
yeah i do i'm sorry after you go i do
have one thing i want to say after you
go yeah no doubt
matt's going to say it now if you want
to get it off now yeah no no it's going
to go afterwards okay
well let me real quick real quick i
forgot to big uh big up fonz
he has a great interview going on right
now chris canel so when you leave here
head on over to fonz's channel i put
that i put that in the chat
nice okay oh sorry you want to get it
yeah no no we're good okay
i think we do got super chat we have two
super chats yeah you want to read that
now
yeah let's get them now uh we got
stitched two dollars which had attic
show is lit return
equals record you have to lie there is
some similarities
yeah we had that discussion on crossfire
the other day then we have mass erect
five dollars of a chat much respect to
the iop love you guys stay
blessed thank you sir you as well yeah
again tremendous show
paris is on fire and like i said you
know what we love to do
and like you said just bring all
different members of the community
together
regardless like i said if you're a gamer
we want to hear your story as long as
you're respectful
and he held it down man tremendous
tremendous advice too okay i think he
gave
for people who you know like i said you
know we're maybe grinding
and maybe frustrated but we've even said
ourselves like one of our things the
lords do all of us
we've been on that show floor we've been
out there in the streets out there the
people king
handing out the shirts you know what i'm
saying putting us in position attic out
here
really helping us with the content
creation and what's going on
in the space and solve you know minding
the clarity making sure we're balanced
and as well as and being forced to
interview people
like i said so i've got my top highest
video i'm still
mad i'm still jealous shout out to toby
yeah to this day
that is our most popular and it was a
soft interview with kkk
what's up it was crazy is cod was doing
the interview on the side
so i was like come on son let's go get
this let's not get out of the park
salute because that's how you do this
grind man and eventually like i said
you will hit it but again and much love
to everybody's community i the love
y'all shown
for me being on next cast was wow like
that was i don't even know what to do
with that i was loving
the whole realm pull up and we're just
like yo we was proud of cognito being up
in there with love y'all
um attic you got anything you got to say
before we pull up yeah so
obviously you guys know uh iop is about
the community we always try to
uplift content creators it's like um
it's like
it's like lord soft said here is fonz's
uh stream
i want you guys to go in there and say
iop sent us
show them love hit that like button man
uh you know it's it's it's really
nerve-wracking to do your first
first show on camera for like for the
first time doing this
go in there and show him look no all i
got
uh well i don't know if you're checking
the discord uh lord josh redding
they kind of agreed that uh the thing
that's been announced
okay cool so look we're gonna be doing
this thing the lord's
minute you know some really exclusive
content that's gonna be
up on lords of gaming.net so please
support it it's gonna be one-on-one
style
we're gonna be talking about the hottest
topics you're gonna have one of us your
favorite lord we're one of the writers
they're gonna be interviewing us
please salute and support it's going to
be something that we're going to be
doing inside we want you guys to come to
the site man launching game.net is fire
and we're going to have the lords now
exclusive one-on-one with your favorite
law school
think about them jrpgs you get out you
want to deal with king think about game
pass you get king you want to know what
solved
think about what's going on with these
single-player games in the industry
highlight of course you know i might
pull up too so
salute and check that out lord's minute
launching gaming.net
most likely every tuesday and thursday
up on lawrencegamer.net so
check that out are we good song one more
for mass
2.00 hit that like button guys thank you
so much my brother appreciate it
everybody enjoy your sunday much love
y'all
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
you